Susan Sontag is an author playwright
filmmaker and human rights activist her
early essays during the 1960s and 70s
examined diverse subjects including
style photography art film politics
theatre and cancer she's the author of
four novels including in America which
received the 2004 fiction her books have
been translated into 32 languages and
her latest work is titled regarding the
pain of others for the next three hours
Susan Sontag will take your phone calls
and email as our guest on book TVs in
debt Susan Sontag as we begin he's been
writing about this country for about 40
years now and through some very
turbulent times Vietnam cold war
assassinations
Watergate this is sort of a State of the
Union question how do you feel about
this country right now well to start
with I don't really think I'm writing
about this country as much as I'm sort
of living in this country because I'm an
American citizen and glad to be an
American citizen and reacting and what I
think is a very particular citizenry
duty that a writer can choose to have
which is be a spokesperson and try to
formulate opinions particularly
oppositional opinions I think that's
very useful to be a gadfly to say
perhaps what isn't being said by
everybody else
assuming that you believe it's true
because I don't believe in opposition
for the sake of opposition right now
like a lot of people in this country and
a lot of people in the world
I am very troubled and concerned about
the new Imperial of policy that has been
enunciated by the Bush administration I
think this is a divided country divided
world and it's very important to have a
real debate with the understanding that
we don't have as much debate in this
country
think as we should particularly on the
political level I sometimes think this
is an exaggeration but I think it's not
an unreasonable exaggeration we really
only have one political party is an
extraordinary consensus or agreement on
most issues between the Republicans the
Democratic Party sometimes I think we
only have one party the Republican party
and it has a branch called the
Democratic Party so although there's a
lot of disagreement on the level of
people citizens in this country I don't
see that debate being reflected in the
same strength by our elected
representatives so that's why I think
it's very important to continue that
debate in any way we can was there ever
a time in modern America where there was
more healthy debate discussion
dissension when there was a stronger
Democratic Party that stood for
something different from the Republican
Party
yeah and was that last uh before Bill
Clinton I think it I think through I
think Clinton adopted a lot of the
Republican positions and the so-called
New Democrats it became very much like
the Republicans something of the same
thing has happened in Britain the new
labor Tony Blair has taken a lot of the
Tauri positions you have the same
problem in the United Kingdom as you
have here where you have a shrinkage of
the opposition party and the dominant
party is just being imitated by and
large by the other party so I don't know
I think of up to about 15 years ago
maybe I don't you know it's complicated
and and also what's so interesting about
this country one of many things that's
interesting about this country is it
there's a lot of decentralized activity
there's a lot of stuff this goes on on
the two coasts that's very different
from what goes on in the in the center
of the country you country doesn't it
isn't any unified saying and I'm I think
the debate is wonderful that's going on
now but it's a debate being led by
citizens journalists other sorts of
people I don't see the Democratic
Party's standing up for the positions
that it should stand up for it to oppose
the Republican Party I don't see why Al
Gore who has nothing to lose
can't can't outline a different position
I live in a state New York State where
both senators voted to support the warm
war powers of the president I don't
think that Schumer and and Rodham
Clinton necessarily represent their
constituents and they're both Democratic
senators the Democrats up to now have
been afraid they say well maybe this
invasion will go badly then we can say
well we never really were for it but
they're not articulating an oppositional
position that's my current concern
that's very very specific because there
are all kinds of large issues of social
justice what's happening in our
educational system what's happening in
our environment all these things that I
would like to think about I I wish I
could think about more and I wish I
could get other people to think about
more I don't think there's just the
issue of war but right now that's
certainly what I wake up thinking about
and everybody I know does too Susan
Sontag is going to spend three hours
with us assess in depth series is our
once a month conversation with some of
America's top nonfiction writers about
their craft and about the topics they
cover we're going to go to phone calls
in about 15 minutes we'll put the c-span
2 phone numbers on the screen here at
both TV and you can also reach us by
email we have an email address that will
give you and we very much want to make
you part of this conversation we'll do
that in just a few minutes tell us about
your latest please well that's book
which has a very stark title regarding
the pain of others and it has a very
stark image on the cover it's actually
an image by Goya from his famous print
series that go ahead did in the early
19th century called the disasters of war
it shows of Spanish resistant and a
French who's been hung hanged and a
French soldier who's just watching him
so it rates in a very literal way the
title of the book what the book is about
is well I think if it is a book about
war tell you the truth well I think a
lot of people because I wrote a book
called on photography I'm going to think
it's a book about photography and I am
completely haunted and absorbed by the
subject of war not just because of the
current crisis the current war plans of
the United States but because I've had a
direct experience of war I've been
actually in three wars president three
wars and in the third and most important
of those experiences when I spent a
large part of three years in Sarajevo
between 1993 and the end of 1995 during
the siege I had the unique experience
because that was a siege but I was
fortunate enough to have un credentials
to enter and leave the city when I
wanted to to be in the middle of the war
and then going out for a couple weeks
take a bath get stuff to bring back in
and seeing how the war was reported to
have the direct experience of the
difference between being in a war and
seeing a war at a distance knowing it
largely through photographed images as
still photographs and of course
television so what this is about is how
we perceive war and other kinds of
disasters and atrocity when we know
those situations through images and I'm
particularly concerned with the question
that has come up so often and I'm afraid
I'm partly responsible because it was an
idea that I had when I wrote about
photography many years ago in a book
called on photography that when we look
at these images of disaster and horror
and then we have this nightly atrocity
show that we get a new word that we get
desensitized that we don't care anymore
I used to think that I don't think that
anymore and that so the book is partly
kind of quarrel with myself about what
the effect and impact of all these
images of war that we watch so in that
sense it is a continuation of an
something I was talking about a long
time ago in this book called on
photography but it's really about how
people can take in the suffering of
others you could extend it of course to
how thick in the suffering of other
people that they know how do you deal
with some terrible thing that happens to
somebody else do you run away from it do
you deny it do you stop feeling it
how do you protect yourself how do you
intervene when do you feel you have to
intervene or you should have a view
about something I mean it's a moral
question I think there's a political
aspect to it but it really is about how
we are constituted as moral beings can
we take the whole sufferings of the
world on our shoulders are we supposed
to be reacting to everything feeling we
ought to intervene how do we select what
we react to I mean it's about questions
like that now when on photography came
out and one of the interview she gave at
the time I read that you didn't own a
camera is that still true yeah yeah well
no I don't well I actually have been
given a camera by friends who think I
should take pictures I guess I'm afraid
of it in a way I love photography so
much I think it's the I don't own the
camera for the same reason that I don't
own a chess chess set I mean somebody
once tried to teach me to play chess and
I quickly realized that this could be
incredibly addictive activity and I have
enough addictions already so no I don't
take a pictures but I look about
pictures I look at pictures that's think
about pictures all the time I think we
all do I mean it's so extraordinary how
much our sense of the world is now ruled
and shaped by photographed images and
then there is that very interesting
phenomenon that we can look again and
again at the same image for instance
this show which we're doing live will be
rebroadcast rebroadcast rebroadcast and
archived for an emergent exactly now in
an earlier time call it a pre-modern
time when something happened it happened
you couldn't react spear Ian sit then
they're all the ways in which we have
knowledge through photographic imagery
that are unprecedented you go to a
basketball game and then in the
intervals you will see the shot which
which you saw as a member of the
audience you'll see it on a very large
screen in slow motion and you can see it
as through the camera as you never could
see it even though it was something that
you actually saw with your own eyes
before camera
and slow things down it could speed
things up it shapes it frames it chooses
and these images get stocked and there
are archival images that turn out to
define how we think of the world for
instance if you think of the Second
World War the European Second World War
the Nazi era I think almost the first
thing that comes to people's minds would
be the images of the concentration camps
that were taken via phone aggress that
were taken of the survivors in Dachau
and Bergen Belsen after the war and well
when the camps were liberated in April
1945 those images really sum up the cars
of the Nazi era and you could almost
think that one of the reasons that we
didn't know the horror of what went on
in the Soviet Union in the gulag and
elsewhere is we didn't have photographs
there there we don't know really what
happened in the Korean War in the way
that we know what happened in the
Vietnam War because there was very
little photographic and television
coverage of the of the Korean War in a
certain sense the things we pay
attention to now are the things that are
photographs that we they're given to us
in the form of images and that's a real
change in consciousness not to mention
that you can know yourself through
photographs let's say how you looked as
a child and at all ages if your family
took a record photographic record we we
know so much through photographs that we
never could before what about television
what's your relationship with it oh well
I'm a notorious freak on the subject of
television but I hasten to add that I go
to about five or six movies a week so
and I mean latterly I mean I mean movies
and movie theaters and so if I don't
watch television it's just a
a sacrifice which I make in order to
free time to go to the movies and read
and listen to music and look at art and
hang out with people and actually even
get a little work done when I can resist
all the things that that I enjoy doing
however the coming of DVD and the
computer has even changed my relation to
television because now when I want when
I do want to watch these things which I
was depriving them myself of like The
Sopranos then all I have to do is buy
the DVD and I can watch them on a large
screen of my of my of my main computer
so I'm not missing everything
in what ways let's just stay on that
subject for a minute it has all of this
new technology the computer to write on
the Internet to research on changed you
in your craft I don't think the computer
has changed anything except give me a
great deal of pleasure I don't do any
primary research on on the Internet
although I'd check things I find the
that using books is still more helpful
and useful and I can find my way around
better I mean it's true I could look up
words in the dictionary on the computer
but the dictionaries are right there in
the room anyway so well I'm not lazy
it's good for me to get out of a chair
and go to the bookshelf as for the
writing itself which I do do on a
computer it doesn't change anything
I was always a fanatical rewriter so the
fact that it's easier to do it on the
computer than our typewriter doesn't
change anything at all but what the
computer is is a fantastic means of
communication I do an enormous amount of
emailing and and I'm part of and this
has been got wonderful of what I I guess
in the 18th century they used to call
correspondence Society there are about
25 people that I exchanged emails with
about stuff that interests us right now
it is about the coming war ille acid I
don't think was anyway stopping this
government to the becoming war in Iraq
and we send each other stuff from all
over the world from different news
sources and and become better informed
through the computer
I remember years ago when people tried
to talk me into the computer and they
said it's so much fun and I said very
starchy I don't need my typewriter to be
fun well of course that was a very
stupid thing to say because you can't
have too much fun and it's actually a
lot of fun but I don't feel it's changed
anything I mean some people say that it
does change the craft every think it
changes anything at all it's just a
fabulous resource and way of staying in
touch with people and in particular
subjects for instance medicine there I
think the computer has been incredibly
empowering when I had a I was a disciple
of it laughter when I say it I had
cancer the first done because I've been
twice a cancer patient this was in the
late 70s and I had a very advanced
cancer that I was diagnosed as being
terminal in stage four and I started
reading a lot of medical books and
asking my doctors questions and fighting
for a better treatment I was thought to
be very weird and many people said to me
well where did you get these medical
books and I said I got them at Barnes &
Noble I mean I went into a bookstore and
said where's your medical book section
they didn't know you could actually buy
medical books if you were in a card
carrying a professional professor but
professional in physician or nurse or
whatever and when I was getting
chemotherapy and I would ask because you
get it in a very large room it's kind of
a beauty parlor from hell you know
you're in kind of chair that tilts back
and anyway others around you and others
around you and you start you're there
all day and you start talking to people
if they you can compute they're not
suffering too much to want to engage in
conversation but anyway I would say to
people what are your what drugs are you
taking because chemotherapy is always
administer as a cocktail it's usually
least three drugs sometimes four drugs
most people would say chemotherapy they
could not say the words they didn't know
them they didn't think to ask their
doctors okay cut to twenty years later
four years ago I'm a patient again a new
primary cancer
I'm in the chemo room I say to people
you start chatting what drugs are you
taking every single person knows the
name of their drugs people are
exchanging protocols and medical
information that they've downloaded from
very good sites you know there's a pairs
of the American Cancer Society Johns
Hopkins Medical School there's something
I believe called unco web there are
wonderful sites where you can get a lot
of information the same people who would
have hesitated to go into bookstore
because that would seem very exotic and
weird have no problem logging on to
authoritative medical sites to get more
information to become more intelligent
patients who can enter into a dialogue
with their doctors and get better
treatment because the more you know and
the more you can ask for in the more
active you are the more likely you are
to get good treatment and countries are
very curable disease if you're properly
treated so there's an example where I
just bless the computer because I think
it has been so empowering that's
something I happen to know something
about I'm sure there many other domains
in which the computer by democratizing
information and we know what it means
elsewhere in the world where I'm sure
while in Iran I know I don't know that
much about Iraq but I have friends who
visited Iran and tell me that lots of
people they're able to go to cyber cafes
however repressive the life is there
they still can get into contact with the
outside world get a lot of information
that's been true in China even though
dictatorships tend to want to control
access to the net worldwide information
by and large they are unable to do so so
if the computer is a very very positive
force I think in our lives well we've
given people a lot of areas to go war
the internet cancer writing let's start
with some calls jacksonville florida
you're on the air yeah I guess I'd start
with the topic of war I just finished a
Robert Kagan's book and he says that one
of the reasons there's a difference of
perception of war between Europe and the
United States is is that Americans
actually feel threatened by terrorists
that we are the targets and it gives a
series of example
not just the World Trade Center in the
Pentagon but also the embassies in
Africa and the USS colon that really
Europe has not been the target of
terrorism so that he perceives this as
being the source of probably more
divergence of opinion I was just
wondering on Musante his opinion on this
well I don't agree ultimately with the
Kagan book I've read it very carefully
and I certainly think that some of what
he says is is true I think there's an
enormous simplification that making sort
of Europe Venus and America Mars you
know as if we have two entirely
different cultures I don't believe that
I think they're very important reasons
why the Europeans don't understand our
rush to war I'm I have to say I agree
with them I thought I that means I agree
with a lot of people in this country to
including many elements of the military
who are not so happy about this war
though they are pledged to obey the
commander-in-chief I think that
particular argument is not true I think
the Europeans have a damn and had such a
catastrophic and horrible attack as the
one we had on September 11th of which
thousands of people died but they have
been living I think is almost the
opposite that they precisely have been
living with terrorism there was a lot of
terrorism in the 70s in Western Europe
there still is terrorism in Spain Italy
Italy France the UK England there's been
AI R Astaire er ISM I think on the
country it's precisely because they do
know what it is you know that there are
two things to be said about the states
about our culture we are we have a
culture of victory in which America
always has to be perceived as being
victorious and we have a culture of fear
I feel this is the only country in the
world in which in some parts not in all
states but in some parts it is
legitimate to kill a trespasser without
inquiring who that trespasser is or or
or having any direct menace from a
trespasser in no other country in the
world is that legal the very fact that
you actually in some states have a right
to kill
but who trespasses on your property is
extraordinary that and there are many
ways in which it's a recent film that a
lot of people have seen called
bowling at Columbine which talks about
the culture of fear in this country I
think I would turn Kagan's argument
around and say we're very fearful
country where country in which we're
inclined to it overestimate Menace I
don't mean we don't have enemies and I
don't mean we haven't had terrorist
attacks which by the way I think we'll
have a great deal more of should we
invade Iraq San Jose California
precision sonntag high under kind of
more for the president in his choice
because he is the president and he has
been given the position of making the
choice for the country and we have been
so attacked and Saddam Hussein has been
a threat for 10 years and nothing has
been done well he I'll tell you I'm not
I'm enough of a Democrat small D or a
Republican small are not to think that I
should automatically trust the president
just because he is president I think
that the president is a fallible human
being his particular group which has had
this plan to invade Iraq since the early
90s represents a particular point of
view there's great there great many
people very confident people who think
that it's a mistaken plan the other
thing is that we can constitute any
country as a threat to the United States
once we decide that our job is to be and
to have bases in practically every
country in the world people are going to
mind that I mean what would you think of
a world in which France or Italy or
Venezuela or Norway had bases in
virtually every country in the world at
this moment what I'm afraid of is that a
majority of people in this country think
of Saddam Hussein and Osama bin Laden
are the same person there is no evidence
and I repeat no evidence whatsoever that
Saddam
saying is responsible for the attacks or
an even participant or in any way
connected with the attacks on September
11 what Saddam Hussein is is a horrible
wicked monstrous dictator who has
murdered millions of his own people I
mean there's hardly any dictator in that
in the 20th century or certainly in the
second half of the 20th century as
horrible as he is and that's the fact is
he a threat to the United States not in
a direct sense at all
as a matter of fact as far as of weapons
of mass destruction though North Korea's
is more of a quote threat then Saddam
was saying we're not going to bomb North
Korea given your view of him and his
menace to his people what is the Western
world I use that loosely so
responsibility toward regimes like that
well that's really a difficult question
you see I have to backtrack here in case
there's a misunderstanding I'm not a
pacifist and I am NOT one of those
people like Noam Chomsky with whom I
have agreed on some points I don't agree
on this point who believes that all uses
of American imperial power are by
definition wrong I suppose in fact I
might be called by it in a certain
stretch of liberal imperialist I believe
there are times when great powers can
intervene to prevent atrocities and
should I wish the United States are the
our the consortium of African nations or
Western powers had intervened in Rwanda
800,000 people if not more coming close
closer to a million people were
butchered in in about six weeks time
probably the fastest and most horrible
genocide of our time the United States
refused to call this a genocide the
Western powers stood back I wish they
had intervened the British intervened
not so long ago and Sierra Leone aid to
to stop horrible atrocities that were
going on there where a rebel group was
cutting off amputating arms and legs of
I was for the very my point of view very
belated NATO American led intervention
in Bosnia and in Kosovo so I am a real
problem and which I'm happy to
acknowledge and when I when I do oppose
this intervention it's not that I'm
against all interventions I think that
this one is unnecessary I think it's
opening a kind of Pandora's box we're
going to be involved in an occupation of
Iraq and a reconfiguring of the Middle
East that I think is beyond our military
and political powers and I think there
are other ways to deal with the problem
then invading and occupying Iraq that's
my position it's not that we should do
nothing I think some of course something
should be done and we should have been
done a long time ago Washington DC
welcome to the program good afternoon
and thank you
I'm miss Sontag I have a problem with a
lot of the things that are going on in
America and I have some real questions
about what we're doing we are actually
demonizing people who who we are
perceiving as threats and we are not
doing anything to do justice to the
Palestinian people the same thing is
true of Africa as you just mentioned
including Liberia right now I'm
wondering in the in your own words about
dictatorships isn't America just about
there now with Sharon of above Israel I
am oh gosh it's so hard to you know I
don't want to have a claim to have any
kind of unified view I might my dears
you have to go case by case I am
certainly and openly and on record as
being an opponent of the Sharon policies
I believe that the only way to go is to
for the Israelis to withdraw from the
occupied territories to withdraw the
settlements this is a very going to be a
very radical and difficult procedure but
it is absolutely the only way to go
there should be a Palestinian state and
the settlements must be
dismantled and taken out of the occupied
territories the so-called West Bank the
present administration is not putting
any pressure on on the Israeli
government to do that
the situation in in Israel and Palestine
is horrible horrible I also am on record
as stating and believing passionately
that the attacks that form of warfare
which consists of suicide bombing is
absolutely illegitimate and I think that
it is a disgrace that the Palestinian
authorities have and the Palestinian
resistance movement has resorted to this
I think it's very much not in their own
interest as well as a completely
illegitimate method of resistance but
mi4 a Palestinian state absolutely
mi4 the withdrawal of Israel from the
occupied territories absolutely but one
must not forget this fact of suicide
bombing this ruins everything
if the Bosnians had decided and they
were much weaker than the serbs that
well we can't possibly defeat the serbs
here we are surrounded and sorry over
we've lost most of our country let's
send some suicide bombers to Belgrade
and set off some bombs in movie theaters
or churches or hospitals or schools or
put them in buses that would have been
an illegitimate kind of warfare and I
was totally for the Bosnians and that's
got one totally against the Serbs so I
think that one cannot only speak of what
the Israelis are doing as occupying
forces one has to also stop this method
of warfare that the Palestinians are
using a viewer named [ __ ] Schuster
asks my question for you is concerning
your activities as a human rights
activist playwright cultural critic
author of short stories novels and
nonfiction books is it possible to unite
human rights activism with creative work
or is it preferable to separate actual
involvement with issues
that cry for justice and the practice of
literature or other arts oh well you
know in a certain way of course as
Chekhov said politics is really the
writers enemy because the one thing if
you're doing anything what I don't even
like to call it politics or or whatever
human rights work it's just I think it's
really one duty as a moral human being
but insofar as I get involved in
different causes trying to get a writer
out of jail or participating in some
movement for a cause that I believe in I
really feel that I'm doing this as a
citizen I'm doing this as a as a as an
ethical person I being a writer being a
well-known writer gives me that
opportunity to get heard and I'm willing
to take advantage of that opportunity
but if I understand the question
correctly it doesn't really have
anything to do with literature I don't
believe that that literature is about
espousing your your-your-your views even
though of course there are views and
book scope that's not why we like them
that's not only who loves them I mean it
dusty ASCII was you know it became very
religious he was for the Czar he became
very conservative during the period of
his greatest books though he was
something of a radical you know when he
was very young and of course suffering
horribly for it was sent to Siberia but
we don't read us to excuse books for his
views we read his books we love his
books for their wisdom for their
humanity for their depth for their
seriousness for their moral and
psychological enlightenment and I think
if you think of your work as presenting
your views you're going in the wrong way
so there is a difference I mean even as
there's a diversity in writing essays
and writing fiction
I actually much prefer to write fiction
but the sense that one is of one's own
time and one should stand up for what
one believes kind of takes me away from
writing it's not unified now that's the
problem it's not unified let me just
pick up very briefly because I've got a
caller waiting on the
ese versus the works fiction in the
place does one form verses together have
greater staying power well people in 50
or 75 years turn to your plays to your
novels or to your essays to think well
I've been lucky in that my essay some of
what you're written as long ago is 40
years are still in print and that's very
unusual so in fact there are people who
attack me it's very amusing there's a
whole cabal of people I won't even say
who they are but none of them some of
the viewers will know I'm talking about
who make a specialty of attacking me for
things I said in essays in the 1960s I'm
sorry that's a long time ago and I'm
evolved as anybody who has read what
I've written what knows which doesn't
mean i repudiate everything that that I
said then on the contrary but certainly
I have some disagreement with what I
said that and I don't I think to be
nailed all the time when you're a
continuously productive writer for
something you wrote 40 years ago is a
little weird I'd rather my trying to be
nailed to what I if I'm going to be
nailed or attacked when I write right
now
so to my enormous surprise my essays
have had a much greater life longer life
than I would have thought I say surprise
and maybe I shouldn't be surprised
because I work very hard on them I
rewrite them over and over and over
again I don't treat them like articles I
mean I rewrite sometimes 20 times the
same the same thing but I think fiction
I think I think literature I think
narrative is what lasts and I would I
wouldn't mind if essays eventually
evaporated because I think a much more
of me is in is in the fiction Los
Angeles hello am I on you are hello
I thank you for taking my call
I'm sure I'm not the only one to point
out the hypocrisy of of invading Iraq to
bring so-called democracy and kill
upwards of half
million up and devastate our social
services and our schools at the time
when Bush has given a tax cut thank you
Miss Sontag for pointing out the fact
that Hillary Rodham Clinton and Chuck
Schumer by the way I'm a native New
Yorker didn't just went along with all
these war plans and I was watching
something a town meeting that they had
done in Connecticut where all these
people were saying we are against this
80% of the people who wrote into this
guy's website were against it and he had
the testicles to say well do you want
someone who is going to vote their
conscience or you know do what you want
them to do and you know basically send
your own children in go there yourself
if that's what you want don't send us
with our money thank our thank you very
much any more on that topic a she talked
about it earlier well I I want to see
two parties in this country I think I'm
just going to repeat what I said before
I want to see a real opposition I don't
I mean everyone's so cynical about the
political process now including the
politicians you know that you can just
see it you can just see it on their
faces they're saying well what happens
if I vote and and what will this cost me
in in votes the next time I'm up for
election I mean it isn't it isn't a
question whether you vote your
conscience as opposed to listen to your
constituents I mean that's a completely
false choice there should be a real
debate and there should be several
political parties I would I would know
least two maybe more than two that
articulate different positions we don't
have that now I mean what we have now is
a false we have a lot of cynicism and
superimposed on that a kind of
macho idea of leadership like like
President Bush praises of Prime Minister
Blair for being someone who knows how to
lead translation of that is a majority
of members of his party are against
Britain becoming the 51st state and the
British prime minister doing whatever
the American president wants whoever
that president might be as a Tony Blair
is saying I don't care what the majority
of voters say I don't care what the
majority of my constituents of my party
say I'm going to support the Americans
because it's the only thing that can be
done and what the Americans have done is
something almost diabolical they don't
say anymore that the old sinister phrase
was if you're not with us you're against
us that's already pretty pretty scary
but but I think the phrase of the bush
group is even more sinister if you're
not with us you're irrelevant
so the United Nations is irrelevant
France is irrelevant Russia is
irrelevant
Germany is irrelevant all these
countries which see that there are other
things at stake then the Americans are
willing to admit in this amazing plan to
in effect reconfigure the Middle East
which will start by an occupation of a
country which is oh hey it's Iraq is is
about the size of France
it's a itself a deeply divided country
it isn't even a real country in a
historic sense it was formed in 1920 in
the aftermath of the first world war not
a real country in the sense in Iran is a
real country that's Persia but in Iraq
is a synthetic country composed of three
former provinces of the Ottoman Empire
which the Turks were defeated in the
First World War
and well then was given as part of the
spoils of war to Great Britain most
people don't know this but between 1920
and 1924 the newly formed RAF engaged in
what is probably the first example of
or the first important example of the
bombing of civilians in world history
it didn't happen I mean it was some
bombing of cities in World War one but
very very little but the RAF started a
bombing policy of bombing in rocky
villages villages with no milk that had
no military purpose whatsoever to
intimidate the population and they
boasted of it and Iraqi villages were
regularly bombed by the RAF when Iraq
was formed and became a British colony
between 1920 and 1924 this I think most
people in that part of the world know I
bet they're very few people in this
country who know it and in fact one of
the leaders of that those punitive
bombing raids which went on for four
years in Iraq in in the early 20s was a
man named Arthur Harris a very notorious
figure I think one of the great
criminals war criminals of the 20th
century
he is the person who's called bomber
Harris nicknamed bomber Harris who was
the architect of the British raids that
destroyed all the German cities and he
said you have to kill as many civilians
as possible this is the only way to
bring a nation to defeat he's the person
who developed that policy in the Second
World War by then he was a general in
the RAF but he cut his teeth military
speaking by bombing Iraq now hey here we
are
Kurtz 82 years later and we're going to
bomb Iraq I don't know it seems to me
there's another way we're dealing with
that monster and I repeat monster who is
Saddam Hussein I don't think he's a
threat to us in that sense that we have
to kill a lot of Iraqi civilians and
occupy the country for next 20-30 years
Washington DC good afternoon good day oh
I don't know what to say I think things
are worse any your experience shows you
you said mrs. killed millions of his
people but it's public record for the
Pentagon and it's available at vit W org
at internet sites is only as legitimate
as the sources are as in a book or a
library but the US Pentagon's own
records satellite information their
supplies of the equipment Helmut Kohl
brought the technicians in and directed
we
but she say dragon Cheney Rumsfeld the
poison gas attacks in the 1988 1 million
dead USA Iraq against the range war so
how about formulating your observations
and into a question well I think if I
can interrupt and I don't want it in der
I don't want to call it go away I think
what we are looking at is the fact that
I didn't want to mention it because I
think in a certain way it's not relevant
another way it is of course because its
history we supported Iraq against Iran
we built Saddam Hussein up in the 80s
just as we supported the Mujahideen the
Taliban the instrument of Osama bin
Laden in Afghanistan against the
Russians we backed in the night we beam
in United States government back in the
1980s the very people that we have now
declared at the end of the 90s leaving
of this century to be our enemies they
are in part our creation in part that is
in fact however I'm not so sure
ultimately that's a reason that's a
strong reason against the war now
because you could say or maybe maybe
Cheney Rumsfeld and company do say ok we
were wrong now we're right I'm sorry
I wanted Collin to go on but I think
that's what hello yes hi general Kagame
was in Uganda in nineteen sixty four
years old he left Rwanda and in April
1994 he is coming from Fort Leavenworth
Kansas invading Rwanda from Uganda and
onwards to Congo five million people
have died there and you can talk to
general Keane is the former head and 80%
of US combat troops I can give you
plenty of references you have them look
up john stockwell 13 year old 13 year
CIA veteran a third world traveler calm
it's worse than you think it is these
people are making money killing people
that's all is it spike
well let me follow up hard it's hard to
climb all the trees at the same time but
they're up in a lot of 30 deals well
given that callers pessimism a viewer in
New Fairfield Connecticut emails this
question the horrific is pictured all
around us how can a person direct their
creativity to envision a new and joyous
future well I think that you don't
necessarily link creativity and vision
of a joyous future I think I think what
I think what creativity is about is two
things I think it's about having an
inner life which may sound like well
don't we all have an inner life but I
don't think we don't all have that much
of an inner life or anyway not one that
we tune into very often because of
distractions and obligations and just
the daily stuff and then a lot of the
mass culture tells us not to have an
inner life it tells us just to respond
to the stimulation so I think I think
one thing is to have a real inner life
which means healthcare being inside
yourself being in touch with feelings
that that you don't turn off or shut off
right away it's it's much more than
information sometimes people just pay
attention long enough to get the
information but they don't really have
the experience I don't really have the
feeling that's part of creativity and
the other thing is and maybe I feel this
very strongly because because I'm a
writer and a writer is a very special
kind of creative person I mean that's
different from being a dancer or a
sculptor or painter or welcome also so
many ways of being creative tennis
player cook III what I love I would drop
draws me very much to writing is it's a
way of paying attention to the world
because as I say that the two sides but
it's having an inner life but that's
kind of in some way with drawing within
yourself
but if you need the antidote or the
corrective of forgetting about yourself
I think it's very important to forget
about yourself I think it's very
important not to think about yourself I
think it's very important to think about
the world and you're just an instrument
for tuning into as much reality as you
can now where the joy comes in well
that's just that you can have a lot of
joy however awful things are if you can
connect to people and enjoy you know we
have the word enjoy you know well you
enjoy touching someone or you enjoy
eating a meal or you enjoy taking a walk
or you enjoyed taking a bath or you
enjoy dancing or you enjoy looking at a
painting nobody should be able to take
that away from you but I think to talk
about the joyous future I don't see how
you can talk about the future in those
terms I think it's you can talk about
the joy that you can find and being
alive and being very glad to be alive
and and being in touch with people that
you know in a benevolent and tender way
that's joy but there's no joyous future
I mean we're all going to die and for
one thing and we're also have a chance
to be alive which is absolutely amazing
in the mean time terrible things are
happening in the world and and and
things that and most people living in a
way that most Americans can can't take
in for instance I read recently and I
thought I knew enough to got to know
this but I didn't that only 20% of
people or what my wish would pay people
households only 20% of households on
this planet have a telephone and a
refrigerator so I think probably most
people in listening to this program
watching this program have a telephone
and a refrigerator and they don't know
anybody who doesn't have a telephone and
a refrigerant not talking about a
computer and not talking about sound
system we're not
about a car we're not talking about all
these other things a telephone in the
fridge those kind of very basic modern
things 80% of households on this planet
do not have either of those I think if
Americans could take that in I would do
them a lot of good and that's part of
being connected to the world Boulder
Colorado yes as a former New Yorker
myself I wanted to piggyback on what you
were just saying in your earlier
comments about cyber cafes and citizen
activists knowing more now about medical
knowledge that than before in a spirit
of the New York intellectuals and Philip
Roth and Mary McCarthy and partisan
review and those characters I see
laughing here people are often it's not
just laughing because I didn't expect to
hear their names I think it's great yeah
alternative futures maybe not joyous
ones but people working on future
utopias and
the importance of that I'm wondering
what what you think first about where
people are at today and how they can go
about working together on alternative
futures and towards a better utopia and
secondly where we are and that's truth
first happiness given what you just said
about a difficulty of these joyous
features well I I think that the first
thing is is is it I guess is to get
outside yourself I think we have a
culture now that that very much
encourages selfishness and people and
it's called it's often dignified by the
name of individualism but really it's
just selfishness so I think a human life
Allah we just have this one life and and
life is long actually and that you can
do a lot of things in one life and if
you don't have part of your life be
about other people and I don't I don't
mean just your family or them or the
people that you love most because that's
easy but do something in your community
I don't know get involved in a shelter
for battered women or do
something about education or do those
citizen lis things that in the old
American dream
Americans were all supposed to do to get
involved in some kind of civic or public
activity in your community I mean you
some people like to chase around the
world and do it someplace else and
that's okay to join the Peace Corps do
something but but see your life as
including some kind of service that's
not about you and not about the people
in your immediate circle not that you
shouldn't be kind and generous to them
too that's something we should all do
and we're you're in a culture which is
encouraging us to be very cynical to
stay home and play with our electronic
toys to maximize our opportunities for
entertainment to care about you know all
those things which are against moral
action so I don't I guess I don't even
like to use the word utopia except in
the sense that I think we should all
have an idea of how things can be better
because things can be better there's no
doubt about it things can be better and
every level things can be better you
have to believe that they can be better
because it's just poor fallible human
beings in their positions of power who
are making them as bad as they are and
in some cases they can be replaced by
people who have another idea it's a lot
of work and it doesn't ever come to an
end of course it's just a life project
well picking up on your comments that
life is long in January you never in
seventy right
was that a milestone birthday for you in
any way well it was a birthday I didn't
enjoy having because it's scary I I
don't know why I didn't I didn't
actually mind any of these awesome zero
birthday's up to now maybe because I was
always in another place and I turned 40
I was in China when I turned 50 I was in
France when I turned 60 I was in
Sarajevo and the bombs were falling and
so when I turned 70 just and in January
also odd I better I better clear out
because I I went to Berlin that wasn't a
terribly original place to go but but my
son was there and he has a these are
fellow at the marchant Academy at Berlin
so I just cleared out of town but it's
true I mean being 70 sounds very awesome
and yet of course I mean every older
person will tell you this is and you
don't feel your age at least I certainly
don't feel like I just feel as if a lot
of things are still ahead and I don't I
don't feel despite my two bouts of
cancer I I'm actually physically very
healthy maybe that's why I survive both
of them I feel I feel fine I have
exactly the same energy that I had I
mean listen sooner or later you know the
sack of bricks is going to fall in my
head I mean I mean I'm mortal and it's
all going to all the bad things are
going to happen but up to now despite
this grotesque advanced age I actually
have exactly the same way that I did 30
or 40 years ago I have the same energy
and I do exactly the same things one day
is going to stop but so far I've been
very lucky we should put on the record
at this point it started piano lessons
just a couple years ago yeah well I
would I I think you can tell this is one
of the things I like most about America
is that Americans understand well even
though lots of people have ambitions and
I of course I do too and did and always
did but they understand that you don't
have to do things necessarily in one
order in a given order I think this is a
unique thing in American culture and
it's one of things I like most about
America the idea of the second start the
third start the new start the remake
your life I'll tell you I hope I can
tell you very quickly a story where this
was when I found this out I was once
years ago in Paris waiting in an office
to see friend of mine a film producer
and then she was
go out to lunch and I was just there in
the office and she was late and I fell
into a conversation with the secretary
the receptionist who is a woman in her
late 30s and she heard my very big
American accent in French and she said
oh my boyfriend and I are going to
America next month this was in
october/november son I said what are you
doing said oh we're going to take skiing
lessons in Vermont and I said you could
go to Vermont to take skiing lessons why
don't you go to the Alps hundred other
Pyrenees are perfectly I mean it's not a
kind of big jump for you to go unless
you really want to go to the stage no no
we're just going for the schema I told
why don't you do it here she said oh you
don't understand I'm 37
my boyfriend is whatever 37 38 something
we have never taken skiing lessons if we
go to a place a resort ski resort here
in France or in Switzerland everybody's
going to be in their teens and people
will laugh at us that we are beginner
beginning skiers and we're in our 30s I
said all gonna be ridiculous
she said no everyone will laugh at us
everybody will think we're weird so okay
if you say so anyway my friend French
producer then came out we went to lunch
and I told her the story and I said is
it true I shouldn't oh sure people would
laugh at them now you know grandmother's
great grandmothers can you know can
learn I'm going to parachute and
everyone says right on granny you can do
things at any age here and if anything
you're applauded if you do them you know
go back to school take up your PhD at 65
or whatever so that that is part of the
American openness which i think is well
anyway it helps me get older that's a
very american in that way let miss
michigan you're on for susan sontag does
she think there's anything to do with
the class idea of being a multi-million
dollar [ __ ] in order that the United
States is in the shaper and dr. via TV
and radio signal for people of average
means I'm hoping that happens three
months before the first primary so that
we don't have people selling duct tape
declaring orange emergencies and
castrating the securities exchange
conditions
the bribes can go on the right pocket
and you think if we had to open access
for regular people candidates it went
throw away votes and working
neighborhoods to put the dictator in and
stuff like that well that's a lot of lot
of different ideas let me just say that
something went very wrong in this
country when elections could be bought
and they can be bought it is at 10 in
the long run we can't have a democratic
system if you have to raise tens and
tens of millions of dollars to run for
public office I mean I think that's of
the many accusations which which were
you know which was suggested by what you
just say that's the one that that I
think is really central the connection
between politics and money is not a
necessary connection but now I think it
has become a fatal connection that if
you are if you're a Congress person you
know where you have to run every two
years
everyone knows the minute you you take
you take office you're already raising
money for your campaign two years from
now and that's a big part of what you're
doing that is not true in Europe it is
not true that money depends this is me
it is not true that elections depend on
money and that elected officials in all
the democratic countries of Europe are
spending at least half or more of their
time raising money for their election
campaigns this has to distort our system
I mean if you think go way way back you
know how did somebody like I don't know
Harry Truman run for office how did
Wendell Willkie in 1940 get nominated as
a Republican nominee I mean think of
what it took to be nominated or elected
to public office in this country 56
years ago it wasn't principally money
and now it is next telephone calls from
California to town of gallito you're on
the program thank you I was curious on
your thoughts about journalists being
embedded in the frontlines in Iraq and
also just kind of your has your general
thoughts on photography changed over the
years
thank you
well the first question is a very
interesting one this the sinister phrase
embedding the journalists I won't
comment on that phrase because it's kind
of a hoot isn't it but I do think well
I'd say journalism the relation of
journalism to the military has a history
and the history that interests us and
that mobilizes people like us and I
think we call her and I probably have
some similar views on these matters the
model is the critical journalist the
independent journalist the journalist
who may even be against the war that he
or she is covering this started
obviously in Vietnam but it is important
to remember that it wasn't always like
that
in the Second World War journalists
reporters war the military uniform if
you look back at newsreel footage of the
journalists of print journalists and the
photo journalists in the Second World
War who were covering the war with
American forces they were wearing
American army unit uniforms while the
journalists being embedded in this war
which nothing will stop if this
administration has its way aren't least
not going to be wearing these uniforms
are they going to be independent of
course they're mostly not going to be
independent but look at the Gulf or the
Gulf War of 91 it was actually Margaret
Thatcher and I talked about this in this
book regarding the pain of others was
Margaret Thatcher Prime Minister
Thatcher who set the model in the in the
Falklands War she didn't allow any
journalistic auto coverage to speak of
and that's what the lesson of Vietnam
has been learned that you don't let the
journalists be independent and this
government is going to be no different
than any other government well it would
be in its position to try to limit as
much as possible the coverage of the
journalists out picking up on that mail
from someone who has a professional
interest in asking this question hey it
describes himself as the associate
editor of photo vision magazine and
wants to know why was the decision made
not to include reproductions of the
photographs you discussed in regarding
the pain of others oh that's that's a
very good question I I think of this as
a literary
si I think of it as I think of the si is
a literary form and in the book called
on photography there's these six essays
that were published in the late 70s
those are about photography and that is
as a matter of fact the first book ever
written in any language that is just a
general reflection on the nature of
photography and the meaning that ethical
and social meaning of the omnipresence
of photographic images and the reason I
wrote it is not because photography is
the main thing I'm interested in but
because it is one of the things I'm very
interested in and I was so astonished to
realize that there was no general book
of reflections about photography that
ever been written for that book I
decided not to have any photographs in
fact it didn't even occur to me to have
photographs I was mentioning in the book
photographs that I thought most people
would know or could imagine and it's not
a it's not a picture book with a text
it's a it's a its own I don't know it's
a worth of literature and and I so I
decided that was my decision was my
publisher who said all please don't have
photographs because it's going to make
the book more expensive in fact I think
probably my publisher might have
preferred me to have photographs and
thought it might be more commercial to
do that now for the new book which i
think of at least as much it's not much
more as a book about war seen through
the prism of how we note war through
photographic images it also never
occurred to me to have photographs
because again most of the photographs
I'm mentioning are very well known
starting with rava cappa famous picture
of the Republican militiamen a shot was
supposedly shot as he has profited the
picture and but at the same time I have
to say well quite honestly it's a sort
of sacrifice that I make and I hope the
readers don't experience it as a
sacrifice there was in early December in
the New Yorker magazine a kind of digest
of this book regarding the pain of
others which was published under the
title looking at war and the The New
Yorker editors decided to include
photographs and I yeah you have it there
let me uh I have to say when I saw this
layout I almost burst into tears I just
thought it was so wonderful and so
moving and what you see there I'm
assuming that the television viewers can
see it are twelve of the pictures that I
talked about can you get a little closer
so he knows I was no one on that one the
one on the lower right is is
particularly moving to me it is the
third of a triptych of three photographs
by great war photographer named Tyler
Hicks taken for the New York Times and
it shows the killing of a Taliban
soldier a wounded Taliban soldier who's
been dragged out of a ditch by some
Northern Alliance soldiers who discover
him cowering and wounded in a ditch on
they're advancing toward short Kabul
this picture was published along with
two others in the New York Times and it
was cut the bottom part of it was cut so
you don't have his he's naked from the
waist down and as a very bloody and he's
being butchered by these soldiers you
see I was so horrified horrified to the
point of tears when I saw this these
three photographs by Tyler Hicks Anaya
and I couldn't and I had to talk about
them in the in my essay my little book
because I thought what does it do to us
to look at these pictures what do we
feel when we look at these pictures now
I'm gonna get back to the root of the
question I decided not to include them
but of course I am very glad than you
also publish them and I I want people to
imagine them I want people to see them I
want people to think about I hope that
people can think about what it means to
be Co spectators of these
atrocities Hollywood California yes
hello hello miss Sontag it's so good to
hear a sense and reason being spoken my
question is as a 71 year old I remember
as a very young child seeing the
photographs of the Holocaust coming back
after world war ii and the impact that
had on me and the rest of us and i think
it was a lifelong result which turned me
quite radical in in my view of things
the horror of it the fact it seemed to
me at the time that no one cared now six
years later we're in the same exact boat
and my question is the people who like
yourself norm Tran ski and so many
others who stand so firmly and so
intelligently and so magnificently
against this kind of thing who have the
heart and the mind somehow seem as
irrelevant as our current administration
would make France and Germany and the
rest of them what impact do such people
as yourself really have on our society
which seems to be so steeped in
indifference and stupidity and all of
the rest of it I wonder if you could
answer that it really is very
discouraging to me well part of what you
say this is so close to what I feel in
fact in on photography since we are the
same age as maybe part of it part of the
impact of it anyway one in 1945 when I
was 12 years old I came across the
photographs of the concentration camps
that had just been taken when they were
when they were liberated it was in the
summer of 1945 and I and I saw these
pictures and I say in the last essay and
on photography that I feel that that was
a kind of cut let
I kind of cut in my life that my life
consisted to up to the moment that I saw
those photographs and ever since and
what those photographs told me and and
remember in 1945 you didn't see pictures
like that you didn't see atrocity boat
photographs any more than you saw
photographs of people making love or all
the things that we that we now see in a
very widely distributed public imagery
what that's what that those photographs
told me was that human beings and I say
human beings I don't say Germans that
human beings were capable of
unimaginable wickedness and cruelty and
that one must never forget that they are
capable of other things as well but they
are also capable of unimaginable cruelty
and wickedness and that is the beginning
you might say of moral adulthood one of
the things that drives me nuts is when
people are constantly being surprised by
atrocities and how could this happen and
how could people do this to each other
well we surely have enough knowledge we
should if we are morally and
psychologically adult enough knowledge
to know that human beings are capable of
this and that is should be at the center
of our sense of what it is to be a human
being to understand that that's that
possible high possibility exists in most
people I mean I might say this is a very
very crude that maybe 10% of people in
the world are really cruel and really
wicked and and it takes absolutely
nothing to unleash that and about 10
percent of people in the world are truly
good and truly kind and truly generous
and even at the cost of their lives
incapable of committing a truly wicked
or atrocious attack from another human
being and then the other 80% can go
either way so we have the two extremes
there are people that I think honor no
incentive could ever kill or torture
another human being play ten percent and
another ten percent will do it at the
drop of a hat and the other 80 percent
that's most of us will go either way
encouraged if if it's validated if we're
told it's patriotic if we're told that
if we're not for something we're
traitors we're not Patriots that's the
terrible thing we can all be manipulated
in that way so that for me to those
those photographs were and I've said it
and print a absolute turning point in my
life about relevance about how you feel
that what you do is useful I don't know
I don't know what to say except the old
the old adage you know pessimism of the
intellect optimism of the will in other
words your your your brain tells you
what you're doing isn't going to any
good at all and your will which is your
conscience tells you you must try to
support what is better and then it's it
that you're just one person of many I
mean there's no sense of which I could
change anything I can just be well I can
change maybe I can help get somebody out
of jail I can do particular things that
I have that have been good for a single
person or maybe even more I think my
writings on illness of help people and
even in many cases save people's lives
but the Gupton to go to doctors what
they didn't want to go to a doctor
because they were too afraid of the
diagnosis but we ought to understand our
insignificance and that's why we have to
do things together and talk to each
other and I have to say I'm very
inspired already by this program and the
kind of conversation that I'm able to
have with people whose names I don't
know who take the trouble to call and
say what they think hadn't clearly are
very concerned I think this is this is
part of what's good that we are that we
can have this conversation right now you
know we're almost an hour and 15 minutes
into this conversation and we haven't
really talked about you and part of the
theory of this is not just what you
think but how you got there so let's see
if we can get through a few biographical
details you were born Susan and
Rosenblatt right how and when did you
become Susan Sontag I was my father
who died when I was five whose name was
Jack Rosenblatt maybe I'm going to hear
from some a long-lost relative because
of it because of this I've actually
never talked about this on television
my father was a fur trader in northern
China and my my mother and he lived
mostly in China but they did come back
when I was born and they did come back
three years later when my sister was
born I have a sister named Judith who
lives in Maui with her family and then
they went back to China and then my
father died and then my mother came back
when I was six my sister was three and
then started a series of peregrinations
I mean we had been left with relatives
more or less and there was there was a
weird childhood and we ended up my
sister and I with my mother who was very
much a part-time mother and a nanny in
Tucson Arizona and that's where I spent
a good part of my childhood and then
when I was 12 my mother met a very
glamorous war veteran with full of
medals and shrapnel too had been an
American Air Force and come in with a
with originally actually the Eagle
squadron he had joined up in 1940 and
was with the Eagle squadron which is
part of the RAF and then when the
Americans came into the war he was a 24
bomber pilot he had been shot down six
days after d-day and was convalescing in
Tucson his name was Sonntag he had every
metal except a Congressional Medal of
Honor and my mother married him and she
asked my sister and myself to take his
name I was 12 and my sister was nine he
he did not adopt us so I can't even
really say he was my stepfather but he
functioned
as a stepfather that is he say he was my
very glamorous mother's husband and then
when I was almost 16 still 15 I left
home and went to college well that's the
part if you look at your biography just
at numbers college at 15 marriage at 17
yes a a child at 9:19 if these numbers
suggest what from the the background
you've just described eagerness to get
to grow up I think a childhood was
wasted on me which of course this is a
great pity but I didn't particularly
enjoy being a child and I was very eager
to grow up and why was I here to grow up
it's so funny because childhood is
wonderful and I remember my own son
saying to me when he was about 15 and I
was berating him for some immature piece
of behavior and he said you don't
understand I like being a child of
course he knew me so well that he knew
that this would make me laugh and he
also knew me well enough and I told him
enough stories to know that I hadn't
enjoyed being a child and I just I
wanted to be free i associated adulthood
with being free with being able to go
places and know things and meet people
it would be interested in things I was
interested in because I didn't meet
people like that when I was a child I
was quite self created so that that was
kind of a weird a weird childhood but
then I of course I think I've made up
for it by being to it having a very
protracted adolescence throughout my
adulthood and and I still feel I don't
know it's that whole question of age I
really don't know and sometimes I think
I kidding myself I mean I am the age I
am I am to be 70 years old and then I
was this age then and that not the other
but I actually don't think it matters
that much but again I'm sorry to keep
saying more than I should perhaps but
because every time I think of something
I think of something else maybe it's
just very American to always think you
can invent yourself that you can make
yourself up
I do feel quite self created um I don't
know I I don't know I I always have the
feeling that the I'm just beginning I
even have a feeling now I this this book
regarding the pain of others I believe
is my 16th book and yet I really think
and maybe I'm kidding myself of course
that I'm actually just beginning now or
I'm sort of I just got it now now the
next novel I'm really going to do what I
want to do that maybe the endless
illusion of course but that's what I
feel Nutley New Jersey welcome to the
conversation thank you I just wanted to
thank c-span and also Miss sonntag for
offering a voice of reason and
thoughtfulness that I've not heard in
the media very frequently I was
wondering if if you've noticed a
correlation between some of the
terminology being used to describe the
acts of violence that we're experiencing
lately in terms of terrorism or the
terminology wrapped around terrorism
I've noticed a correlation between that
terminology and also the terminology
used I would think in the 19th century
in terms of savage behavior or
describing certain people's as savages
and their acts as savage against what
what were then really colonial powers
well I I find that all the polarizing
language all the language that that
turns situations into two opposites
I believe almost as a matter of
principle that that has to be a
distortion it has to be a simplification
and and it's just not a principle it's
actually something I experienced I
always want to break down those
opposition's I to words that seem to me
very very poisoned and one should try
not to use them in art art civilization
and barbarism the the it's a very easy
way to mobilize people and to say you
know the way the way the way people
started saying right after 9/11 right
after September 11 you know well this is
an attack on civilization itself
I mean I'm on record and I was much
attacked for it for right away and a day
or two after the attack on September 11
for saying let's not you know be so
self-righteous of course what has
happened is a monstrous crime an
atrocity but we must not simply wrap
ourselves in the mantle of civilization
and say that those who attack us are
barbarians that's too easy and in an
awful way it mirrors the language of the
other side I mean the radical Islam and
that revolutionary current which is
going through the world and which
mobilizes many people is absolutely a
language of polarized opposites
you know the believers versus the
infidels and so on so are we I think you
know I say how do we how do we
understand our privilege how do we
understand how privileged we are and how
how this looks like to the rest of the
world what the rest of the world does
not necessarily think that a world ruled
by the United States would be an ideal
situation there are other cultural
options what do we have in a world that
in which the United States cannot be
stopped
in whatever it chooses to do is a
dangerous situation I mean you might say
and there's an argument that a great
many uses of American power have been
benevolent but safe world war two is the
easiest example that certainly was a
case in which what the United States did
was positive largely positive I exempt
of course the the incineration of the
Japanese cities and the terror bombing
of the German cities but by and large
the United States was certainly on the
right side in World War two but a
country which has an overwhelming
supremacy military and economic so far
exceeding anything known in world
history not to mention anything existing
on the planet today cannot expect always
to act like angels it's very corrupt to
have corrupting I should say to have so
much power there should be
countervailing powers and that that's
something that we should want instead of
claiming the rest of the world
irrelevant if they don't follow
America's orders the world and the
United States I think would be a better
place if there were several centers of
power that's not in that's not in the
works right now we are in a situation
when America is on on the threshold if
current policies prevail if we don't
walk into a disaster now in Iraq with
situations far out of our control in
which we're going to see further and
further extension of Imperial might and
I think this country will change and
that's I think it will not change for
the better
Salt Lake City High citizen I talking
about your comment regarding pessimism
of the intellect and optimism of the
will we were among nine people standing
on the corner protests in more a couple
of weeks ago and we were continuously
attacked by others saying among other
things how could you possibly be against
the war when they attacked us at the
World Trade Center as though they were
completely unaware that Saddam's
in had nothing to do with it and I
thought that was really remarkable but
we said we felt the need to stand and
protest anyway but I think that's great
that veggie did that and that's and it's
that kind of misinformation which is
perfectly understandable listen most
people don't have the time the energy or
or the resources to become experts on
these matters but it is it is of course
very scary to realize that one of one of
the one of the things that this country
kind of specializes in is the enabling
ambush the disaster that then mode is
there is a way in which we can mobilize
whether it's the method blowing up with
the main in the harbor in Havana in 1898
or it's Pearl Harbor or now it's 9/11 I
mean right away and this scared me
immediately and after 9/11 people said
it's Pearl Harbor and then you say hey
Pearl Harbor okay it's a surprise attack
it's a disaster it's a catastrophe I see
the comparison there but is it really
Pearl Harbor in the sense that it's now
the justification for a new world war
what's that now it is true I think that
there is a demonization of the Muslim
world going on I as a woman cannot be
very happy about radical Islam let me
say right away I'm extremely upset
extremely agitated extremely haunted by
the what I would call the war against
women being conducted in this in Islamic
countries but that being said there it
is a fact that that here in this country
and I think elsewhere too in a lot of
Europe every Islamic country is or every
Muslim country is viewed as the same as
every other country and all these names
get mixed up in people's heads and if
it's attacked comes from people who are
thought to be you know from an Islamic
country then they must all be the same
person so again people think Saddam
Hussein it's something to do with 9/11
he had nothing to do with 9/11 they are
not all one person they are not the
Muslim world
it would be horrible if we got involved
in what amounts to a crusade against the
Islamic world that would be a complete
disaster much as I of course hope for
reform in the Islamic world and I hope
for the growth of the possibility of
secularism particularly as it would
benefit that half of the human race that
I happen to belong to namely women I'm
in the situation of women always
concerns me so many emails so many
questions and already halfway through
our conversation the hours have flown
like minutes
Northampton New Hampshire well you know
the reason it's flown by because you
haven't allowed any calls
you just keep chatting it sounds like
the Susan Sontag left this lecture this
afternoon but anyways both Susan's I'd
like to know I've got three questions if
you allow me I mean all the way you talk
you should allow a caller a few moments
and someone who is in praising ole Susan
here I like know what what is your name
sir sir what's your name since you're so
free with my first my name is Decker
bill Decker
okay Belle okay I've just built it mail
to me it's a nom de listen to you Susan
uh I'd like to know what birthday I
served in the Vietnam ease war and in
not in Vietnam and was a prisoner of war
while you were over there and you didn't
I like to what birthday you celebrated
with Oh Chi Minh but you weren't real
popular with we Marines I can tell you
that young lady we were tortured over
there and even though you and Jane Fonda
stood up and said we weren't I never
said anything of the kind you find
excuse me bill you find a place that I
said you were not tortured I know
perfectly well that American prisoners
were badly mistreated in Hanoi and I
have said so I never said anything to
the to the contrary and don't you dare
we explained with Jane Fonda I'm my own
person with my own statements they are
not the same as hers Vietnam you're
there come on with your question okay
you won't answer that one
okay and I also wonder why you don't
have a photograph of your book of that
young CIA agent
Jonnie span who was beaten and eaten to
death by the Taliban and and you say
that there's such polarizing language by
the by the right how about words like
Hitler Bush blood for oil all of these
sort of things that you left us throw
around very very quickly and don't
bother to call that polarizing language
dude and and also the incineration of
the Japanese you're talking about well I
had two brothers in Iwo Jima missus
Sonntag or whatever you are and they
would thank God that Harry Truman had
the sense to save their lives they
survived Iwo Jima and came home and
people like you saying oh my god your
brawny knight now you call it a Russian
well I was in Japan this hiroshima by
the way but anyway I never sent him
Russian bye though but most of you folks
do well I'm not most of the folks most
of the leftist most of those what you
heard me say Hiroshima now excuse me why
are you confusing me with a bunch of
other folks this is not going to get
very far gooden's
there is evidence that there is a tie-in
with Osama bin Laden and Saddam Hussein
that is evidence that has been put forth
that he has paid $25,000 per head for
the killers families who wrote those
airplanes into the Pentagon into the
World Trade Center into that field in
Pennsylvania you deny it you deny that
they're over there today where we
captured one of their top lieutenants
yesterday not a lieutenant a general a
general and we're going to find out a
lot more about this and you folks on the
Left are going to have to apologize for
defending Saddam Hussein and attacking
our great president okay mr. Decker well
let's go at that point thanks for the
call yeah nobody's defending Saddam
Hussein that's for sure there were other
questions in there such as on Vietnam
why did you go to Hanoi in the first
place I went because I was one of the
founders and leaders of the anti-war
movement I was against the war in
Vietnam as a majority of Americans
to agree with me and I went to on a
fact-finding mission along with some
American journalists and it was
absolutely a very educational experience
let him not make any of the statements
that that some other people made I was
completely aware the mistreatment of
American prisoners and in fact made a
point of visiting prisoners in you know
what are horrified by what I saw and we
listen here on Saturday afternoons to
the Lyndon Johnson White House tapes we
have them from the LBJ archives and it's
a chance to hear the president in his
thinking and defense of the policy at
the time but as so many people as you
know Susan so many people involved with
that war have said it was a mistake
of course I you know I weep for the
American soldiers who died almost 70,000
soldiers who died died we believe
millions of millions of Vietnamese
civilians who died I you know let me
just say once more I am NOT a pacifist
but I do believe that most wars most
Wars need not have happened I'll just
start with the First World War which was
about wrecked Europe this was not a word
that had to happen and the fact that
one's loved ones or relatives were in
the war you know like this caller you
know there's a there's a very strong
argument that Japan would have
surrendered without dropping the bombs
and there is a real argument to that
effect an argument which I find
convincing if you have to in order to
say that that those bombers were
justified you have to have to prove I
can't actually prove the wrong word of
course you have to reason that Japan
would not have surrendered that it would
have taken an invasion occupation of
Japan to make Japan surrender and I
don't believe that that's the case and I
think there's evidence it's not the case
what's really horrible and this is the
thing to get back to is that modern war
there is such a thing called modern war
let's just talk about war in general
itself in modern war modern war is
mainly war against civilians and that's
why it's so horrible and that's why we
want to limit it
let me just give you two facts in the
First World War which was an
unbelievably lethal war and that
basically wrecked Europe and all the
horrors of Stalin and Hitler and so to
follow from what happened as a result of
the first world war in the first world
war ninety percent of the casualties and
they numbered in the many millions were
soldiers
ten percent were civilians in the Second
World War
ninety percent of the casualties were
civilians I mean you know I talked about
the incineration of Japanese cities
where more people died in the bombing of
Hamburg than died in either the Allied
bombing of Hamburg than died in either
Hiroshima or Nagasaki and the vast
majority of these people were women and
children the vast majority because
bamberg had very few men at that time
and almost all hundreds and hundreds of
thousand people died in the bombing of
Hamburg and they were all women and
children now that's what modern war is
and that's why we have to outgrow war I
think because war has become mainly
targeting civilians if war could still
be fought between armies I think we'd
have more case for war than we have now
and that's that's something I want to
keep coming back to what war actually it
is it isn't always the same thing it's
what it's become because that caller was
the critical voice and we haven't had
many let me add and go back to his
question about the use of language by
people on the left and whether or not it
is also a polarizing force the example
to gave blood for oil
bushes Hitler etc sure I would never say
anything with God mr. Bush although
illegitimately elected is certainly
legitimately the president of the United
States as ratified by the election of
2002 I do not believe I don't I hate
people talk about leftist and rightists
anyway I don't you know even consider
myself a person I left I think these
think these labels are absolutely
obsolete I suppose if I had to choose
I'd still say left but I don't want to
choose because I think there's stupid
labels I don't call people leftist
writers I certainly don't call myself
either of those things I'm very
conservative in some matters and I'm a
libertarian in other matters which is
both a left
right position I would never say blood
for oil and I would certainly never call
mr. Bush of anything but not by the way
neither does any intelligent person I
know including a lot of people would
identify with the left this this kind of
language is of course absolutely stupid
but it's people like the caller who have
to see all the opponents as one thing
you know and they're not all one thing
there for instance when I went to the
demonstration in New York on the 15th I
had the feeling that a lot of the
demonstrators were pacifist or at least
they were advocating a pacifist position
I certainly think that's true in Europe
I think pacifism is a very widespread
position in of all places Germany
Germany is now a country I suppose we
should be very glad since Germany
plunged Europe into three horrible Wars
1870 well that was just friends and then
1914 and a 1939 you have a country in
which pacifism is probably the leading
position among people so when they are
objecting to the proposed war when
they're demonstrating against it they're
demonstrating from a pacifist position
that's a different position from mine
I'm not a pacifist so I think you can't
call it all leftism I knew these words
are just kind of mud in your head I
don't they don't help to understand
anything Los Angeles Gretchen it's not a
good afternoon I am I'm curious as to
why the historical novel seems to be
your preferred genre of fiction writing
and you still feel as you did in your
essays and against interpretation that
in comparison to other art forms in the
20th century such as painting and dance
the novel has evolved the least
Wow well I don't want to hear yes thank
you in America yeah that's the one that
got the National Book Award to my great
surprise and pleasure it's so wonderful
to have a question about literature I've
written two novels the other one is also
on the table there of there the last two
novels that I've written is called that
one is called the volcano lover and the
more recent one that came out two years
ago is called in America and they both
take place in the past and the volcano
lever takes place in the late 18th
century mostly in Naples in Italy and
the the recent one in America takes
place in Poland and mostly in the United
States but some polish émigré who come
to the United States in the late
nineteenth century
I think these two books are the two best
books I ever wrote if I can be permitted
a a biased opinion they might be my two
favorite books that I ever wrote and and
they do both take place in the past and
I have to say that thinking of myself as
a historical novelist it is a sort of
shock to me I guess a little bit like
thinking I'm 70 years old
I guess it's true but gosh I don't think
of them as historical novels I just
thought of him as novels that took place
in the past but then that maybe maybe
I'm being coy maybe I'm being I don't
know maybe I did something I'm just
refusing to see I I guess the reason I
resist the term historical novel is I
think it was kind of a genre like you
know I guess Raymond Chandler wouldn't
want to just be called a detective
novelist he'd want to be called a
novelist because I think he was I think
Raymond Chandler is a terrific writer
he's not just a genre writer he goes
beyond that and so I think these words
like comic novel historical novel crime
novel
Western novel you know is Larry McMurtry
a Western novelist those novelist you
know I I guess as a as a novelist I get
defensive because I think oh they're
putting me in a box but again maybe
maybe I'm just being super sensitive
here maybe there is something that I
have to face up to which is the
following then I found a freedom I never
knew I would find writing about the past
right not writing about the test that's
even one sitting stories in the past so
I felt that I dropped a lot of
inhibitions that I had for tonight that
I never could get rid of I mean I could
be more epic I could be taking more
reality I could have lots of different
characters instead of just seeing
everything from one person's point of
view which the two earlier novels were
very much focused like one inside one
person's head and about the novel itself
well you know it's one thing to write
about novels and or fiction I when I
went out those essays in the 60s they
were very insolent you know like a young
person's work you just want to try to
criticize things and establish your own
point of view that's that first book
against interpretation which i think is
right under there the yeah there it is
that I at that moment I was movie crazy
I liked it guess I've been movie crazy
all my life I've already yeah yeah well
Isis I still AM and I was saying why
can't when the almost be is wonderful is
movies every night said they sound very
silly and I thought novels were stodgy
they were they didn't go fast enough
they weren't intense enough I mean I
they were kind of you know they were too
step by step I felt that they didn't
have the velocity and intensity that I
was looking for in art I'm not talking
about novels of the past because I was
talking about the kind of novels that
were being written at that time you know
and I when I was growing up being a
student in 1950s and and when I first
started being a writer in the 1960s so I
described the novel is very
you know basically a kind of not quite
up to speed form I I don't know what I
think now you know being a practitioner
I guess I'm not thinking so much I can't
be outside and inside at the same time I
think the novel has a great future let's
put it that way I'm not one of those
deaf of people you know people who say
you know vessel intellectuals the death
of the novel the death of seriousness
the death of public morality the death
of democracy that you know the death of
culture the last bissell acid I I know
that's very seductive to to be a
doomsayer and and find your own time so
degraded and so lacking in principles
and standards and energies and and and
and and ideals I try to resist that of
course it's a part of me that agrees
with it to I mean I do find young people
singularly uh no even if they are
idealistic they don't know how to be
they don't know what the justification
of it is they they rather pretend to be
cynical I mean that kind of disturbs me
but mainly I like to think it's not a
joyous future there's a there's a big
future still for all of these things at
one love have a callers been waiting for
quite a while could you give Harry Beck
a quick answer to this question okay
someone wanted to read one book that
would convey the essential Susan Sontag
which book would you suggest I know
almost nothing about you but your name
and many others probably share this
distinction with me
I'd say either of the two novels would
be the books that I would recommend the
volcano the last two novels and a
volcano lover in America I think I put
more of myself in those two books and I
think they're really good reads too yeah
Glencoe Illinois thanks for waiting
you're on the air hi this is Kevin
Susan a great admirer of yours of your
work now I'm very critical of the
motivation of our administration and the
secrecy that surrounds them in fact
that's what worries me almost more than
the threat of war in the larger picture
however my question is the following
because I try to
open mind that is what is they're
smarter than we think we we think they
are and what if the threat and the
build-up really is intended to disarm
without having more and what if all
these protests really are undermining an
intelligent way that they might be going
about it now we don't we might not know
this but that's a possible reality okay
first thing I do not underestimate the
intelligence of this administration I
think one of the many stupid things that
was said by people who didn't vote for
mr. Bush which of course includes me
is that he's stupid and the people who
surround him are stupid and these are
Neanderthals and so on I think there's a
very very smart bunch of people I don't
know any of them personally but I have
no doubt that these people are very
intelligent and their advisors are very
intelligent so the issue of their
intelligence is not is not there's
something if the question is their
policies there there is a group of
people represented by people like alive
Donald Rumsfeld and Paul Wolfowitz and
Richard Perle and so on who have a very
particular take on Foreign Affairs
seconded by other people who have come
in and out of several administrations
like Elliott Abrams and William Kristol
they have a very very particular take on
the world situation on the role of the
United States and a particular focus on
the Middle East on the and those people
with their plans have come to power if
you read Bob Woodward's book for
instance you see that in the
deliberations right after September 11th
the the issue of invading Iraq was
raised and I'm practically in the form
that Bob would reports and say well we
do we have to Afghanistan first in Iraq
second or do we do Iraq first in
Afghanistan second and there is a
memorandum memorandum which has been
widely circulated proposing Lee an
invasion of Iraq
the day practically into 1998 in the
Clinton area and weather was rejected so
they have a policy and this policy can
be challenged because it is a policy of
a particular group of people I'm I will
not say click I mean because that's an
inflammatory language I just say a
particular group of people come to power
and that they're following this policy
the policy is very debatable to say the
least
large sections of the military and of
wall street oppose it not to mention a
large part of citizens as a number of
citizens in this country and form people
abroad for that debate to become open I
think is only to the good wit now the
invasion is going to happen nothing is
going to stop these people in my
estimate if if they are lucky if we get
away with it if we have an open
Pandora's box and brought whole series
of catastrophes down on the Middle East
because we shouldn't always be thinking
about ourselves so those are real people
out there then in in retrospect the
invasion it is possible that this policy
may be justified I I do think it is
possible that it may be justified I
think the odds are against it and it's
on the basis of my belief that the odds
are against it that I oppose the war not
that I think it's impossible that it
could be justified because I totally
deplore or Saddam Hussein regime what
I'm saying is I think this policy is not
the only way to deal with it if you
joined us recently this is a three-hour
conversation with Susan Sontag it's a
series we do on this network called in
depth once a month the first Sunday of
each month or 1 hour and 15 minutes left
to go next call is from Oahu uh-uh
my name is lil Aloha hello I am a native
person here in the island and I do not
agree that Probert defines us here and
as a matter of fact you know you can go
back to 200 years next defining of Oahu
no I would never say Pearl Harbor to ban
Hawaii I know but that's what tell me
that and I got not open to it but please
don't tell me don't find me with what
other people say
I have a sister live as well for many
many years in Maui so I feel some
interesting not in Hawaii yeah well to
lead up to my question here I'm like a
hundred years into the gospel salvation
which is a Phillips College ideology and
it really started 200 years ago so I I'm
a student at University and I used long
period as far as everyday life I'm a
Vietnam vet wise used to be and now I'm
a firefighters life and so I go from
public safety to war and then back over
to public safety
that's the spectrum that I that I sort
of run up and down each day of my life
also I'm a native and I'm more concerned
about in 1990-91 I believe it was UN or
sorry I don't have my citations front of
me so I can't get give you the exact
dates or or at the that's fine what's
the question else
the question is human rights women and
native people and children
having the right I mean as women or
grandmothers we a native to Pacific
Islands or Islander we should have the
right to always feed our be able to feed
our children and we don't we that's our
daily front every day is that right to
feed our children and I'm not talking
about going to the stores and and
purchasing a box of cereal I'm talking
being able to go to the ocean and access
the ocean and fish or go to the
mountains and access the mountains for
fruit and um that's our daily front
that's our daily frontal well you know
what I would say to what you're saying
is and it is very interesting here the
whole sort of burden or content of what
you were saying is a lot of different
pieces of information is that is your
involvement with something very local
you know whether it's your life
your husband where you live of the sea
that surrounds you your concern for
women and children you're saying here's
here's what I care about that's that's
what I get out of what you say you say
here's what I care about I care about
what I know and what surrounds me it's
kind of interesting you know that you
live in an island and I mean it's part
of an American state but it's an island
and I think I think Island people
sometimes have that have that feeling
that well you know it's enough here
we're surrounded by the by the water but
in a certain way life is complete here I
don't want to be defined or have to get
too involved with what goes on
everywhere else but I think you know as
the poet said no man is an island I
think in the end I'm sure it must be
kind of great to live on an island in a
way and and turn things off but well I
can't do it anyway I mean I I've chosen
to do something entirely different which
is I live in a world city a city full of
foreigners every time I go out in the
street I live in New York City I'm
reminded that the rest of the world
exists not just the United States just
by the presence of foreigners and I mean
local life in the place that I live is
an anthology of the world if there is
there is I guess is a native people in
New York in some sense I don't know what
those would be
but mainly I live in a way that there's
always reminding me that I'm not on an
island
so I think it's great if you could be on
an island but I think most of us camp
John in Iowa City wants to ask about
this book which was published when just
well that this book is actually two
books into the first book is called
illness as metaphor and it was published
at the end of the of the 70s and it
flows from and was inspired by my
experiences as a cancer patient it's not
about those experiences but it's about
ideas I had about illness because I was
a cancer patient and the second book
aids and it's metaphors which I never
intended to write but then I did and
then somehow it seemed like a sequel was
written in the late 80s and I had to do
with the fact that I not only became
aware of aids like everybody but I lost
a number of close friend stage he asks
where is the aged metaphor now where
well it isn't the AIDS metaphor it
really what the idea is the idea of
these two books very simply it's that
illness is used metaphorically that you
that it's not just a reality of physical
reality if something happens to you or
love or something
the end happens to all of us it's it's
it's used to describe other things
because what's a metaphor it's something
that you know or something is compared
to something else
so for instance if I could just before I
get to AIDS talk about cancer cancer
it's regularly used as a synonym for
evil people are always saying you know
the Palestinians say that Israel is a
cancer in the Middle East and them you
know and the you know Hitler said the
Jews are you know cancer in the German
body and somebody named Dean said that
Watergate was a cancer on the Nixon
presidency and it's very interesting all
these uses of cancer to describe as a
Sharon or one of the Sharon people
recently talked I can't remember who it
was something about the Palestinians and
using Lee as a cancer image it's really
strange if you are a cancer patient to
realize that your illness is being used
as a synonym for evil nobody's saying
that something is the heart attack or
something there's the diabetes of a need
to mean it's a terrible situation with
cancer
is is used as something ugly something
that has to be cut out of something
that's invasive something that's evil
and this is a tremendous psychological
burden for patients who have this
illness which after all just to say very
simply cancers just an illness it's just
an illness like every other illness and
it's a highly curable illness if you get
good treatment and it's surrounded by
all these myths and associations and so
on
so that was my original insight in the
first book and then I saw how all kinds
of metaphors surrounded aids uh and and
and it's kind of interesting also you
know when aids came up I thought the
myths about cancer at least in this
country started to atrophy they started
to fade it's as if there can only be one
disease at a time that's really
demonized and the disease that people
were really afraid of in the late 80s
when his aids not cancer that was the
one that there was a tremendous public
hysteria about I mean a stereo which
happily has abated but I can remember
going when this book came out agent its
metaphors I remember doing a public
radio program about it in Boston and
when I when I came in I was told that
the person who had spoken before me on
this radio show had AIDS and if I wanted
they would take that microphone away so
that I wouldn't be close to a physical
object which in which a person who had
AIDS would preceded me you know by a few
minutes had breathed on and I said
excuse me I'm not there's not my problem
I know it's just not contagious I've got
I'm not phobic but people were very
phobic that problem is you see that
people AIDS is infectious but it's not
contagious and most people confuse
contagious and infectious and so there
was tremendous fear and that when that
was about that fear now I think to
answer I took a closer anyway to an
answer to the question I think there is
less fear now I think by and large there
was an extraordinary response to this
illness because a lot of the people who
got HIV / aids as we should correctly
refer to it were educated people and
white people and articulate people they
were able to mobilize public
institutions in public sympathy and and
public resources for AIDS and I think
there was by and large a very positive
response when some of the hysteria died
down now of course um hiv/aids is is
more and more an illness of poor people
and we're often people of color and
people who don't have the same resources
to defend themselves to advocate their
their interests and and it's as if that
shadow has has passed for many people
when in fact AIDS is a greater and
greater danger to the world there will
be a net loss of population in Africa
AIDS is just beginning in India and
China
it's a colossal world tragedy not at all
as it was conceived of in the 1980s as
as an as an illness of white gay men
much much larger than that so the here I
think attitudes are relatively positive
in the rest of the world not at all
Santa Barbara California welcome to the
program oh hello well I wanted to talk
to you a little bit about what's going
on in literature and as you know c-span
had done it in depth hang on Jack
Kerouac and seems to me that Jack
Kerouac got away from the use of
narrative got away from the use of time
and history and went into more of a
spatial kind of writing and isn't it
true that in this postmodern
phase of literature that writers are
starting to focus in not on history or
the past or ideas of you know like you
were saying a binary logic but aren't
they sort of viewing the world the
postmodern world in terms of the
dynamics of space and by doing that
they're able to concentrate on
individual difference well that's a
that's a complicated thought and I guess
if you gave me more examples I might
find it more convincing but just
straight off I think I don't find it
very convincing first of all I think
space is a big category in American
fiction for a very obvious reason we're
a very big country we're continental
country and there's an awful lot of a
sense of space sense of physical
grandeur in American literature
I mean think think of the essays of
Emerson for instance Emerson was very
much about space and very much about I
think is a big jump sort of repudiation
of of history there's an amazing
sentence in Emerson where he says he
talks about a dream he's he had and he
says that he saw the world shrunk to a
ball in his dream and then he says this
amazing sentence he said and I ate the
world as a lot of amazing spatial images
in an Emerson there's one look at Moby
Dick is it Moby Dick about space about
voyaging and Whitman certainly I mean
tremendous pictures of the extent and
therefore the diversity but I think
pretty much in a present
keeping in a register of the present
I mean Whitman's an epic poet but it's I
don't think as much of it at leaves are
a history minded I think he's space
minded so I think Kerouac is maybe a
miner forgive me for not being an
enormous fan of care or a kind of minor
heir to what is a central theme of
American literature which is space
eating space admiring and space eating
and you know on the road on the road
there it is and it's in a lot of
wonderful American movies too so I think
it's very American but I don't know that
I would say it's particularly postmodern
and I have to say I'm not really happy
with the term postmodern about the only
place where I use it and then usually
disparagingly is in architecture because
I think it does have a meaning in
architecture it does there is a actually
a movement among architects to repudiate
classic modernism you know the Box Mies
van der Rohe and Corbusier people like
that so I think it does have a meaning
in architecture too but when I hear
postmodern literature I really don't
know what it means I've been called a
post modernist and I missed we called a
modernist and then I think insofar as
postmodern means anything and I it's a
word I don't like to use I just think
it's another way of talking about a
certain kind of modern way of doing
things and that's what fragmented into
so many different ways of writing
actually the truth is if I think about a
lot of American books that are very
ambitious and very admired they are
concerned with history I mean al
doctorow for instance who's a terrific
American novelist is very concerned with
history and sets a lot of his stuff in
the past pension of course Don DeLillo I
mean some of the most admired and
ambitious American writers I think are
their space leaders but they're also
very interested in the history I
wouldn't want to give up one for the
other just beginning our third and final
hour with Susan Sontag meticles from
Manhattan hello thank you for taking my
call the Sontag you are fabulous I
really love you I'm an upper west side
and
I like to go to a Segway first byte
referring to that mr. bill the aunt the
vibram I believe he was a victim of our
own government France had been in the
years and why we went in there to the
state I don't know that was never a
declared war we have had 22 incursions
war by any of the name is still killing
mutilation and destroying of property
and animals of all sorts now we're going
into another supposed police action or
what do you want to call it we have a
Constitution of the United States both
houses of Congress had taken an oath of
office to preserve protect and defend
the Constitution they're not doing that
are they I have spoken to various
elected officials and they slide over I
don't get an answer and now you do
believe so much in the Constitution what
why do you think that they avoiding this
aspect of what's going on well well you
know obviously I agree with you in large
measure but I foreign policy is not
conducted democratically and what we
listen Robert Byrd wonderful elderly
Senator Robert Byrd from West Virginia
delivered a great speech in the Senate a
few weeks ago which I read and kind of
sent around to friends by this email
correspondence society that I spoke of
at the beginning of the program and I
think he articulated very well the the
argument against the war he was behaving
like a senator why is he almost the only
one the governor or ex governor of
Vermont I'm sorry I'm not sure which it
is mr. dillagi see is he still governor
no he's x7m front has made a speech
recently in which he articulated a
difference I mean that what scares me
what scares me what what disheartens me
I should say is that we don't have we
have very very few elected officials
very few people
who
err to run for public office who can
articulate the reasons why we should not
go to war in Iraq and once again because
you can't say this too often I deplore
the tests despise loathe and hate the
regime of Saddam Hussein as I do many
other dictatorships in that area in that
region of the world but invading and
bombing and occupying Iraq I think is
absolutely not the way to go for all the
reasons that many of our European
friends who are now described up as
irrelevant have articulated this is not
the only way to limit this dictators
power and to assist is overthrow which
of course I heartily await the overthrow
of Saddam Hussein as I await eagerly the
overthrow of the theocracy which which
rules and deforms that great country
which is Iraq but the United States
should not take on itself the American
administration speaking in the name of
the American people with something like
a royal we not a we the people but a we
of this administration and this this
particular group are very fanatical in
my view and and imprudent ideologues do
not speak I believe for the best
interests of this country that's what
concerns me I don't think this policy is
in the best interest of this country
back to your writing you've had a career
long relationship with for our Strauss
publishing house why well that's a nice
question
I am extremely lucky lest I might say by
the extraordinary fact and I think I am
the only writer ever to have had such a
bunch of history I wrote it when when I
was in my late 20s I wrote a novel
called the benefactor which was not the
first book I ever wrote but the first
book I thought was worth being published
I took it down in a box and left it with
the receptionist in at Sarah Straus and
Giroux this very eminent small smallish
literary publisher in the
I'd made a list of ten publishers that I
was going to try to get the book to be
published by fairest Ross was first I
think not was second I think New
Directions was third I was just picking
publishers I didn't know anyone in
publishing I just picked publishers who
had published books that were on my
shelves and I particularly liked and I
left it on the chest and it said not a
little note to the fiction editor I had
this crazy idea these stupid idea that
there would be somebody called the
fiction editor and then I said you know
dear sir or madam I am submitting this
book for your consideration this is my
address and two weeks later or three
weeks later I had a call from a senior
editor at Ferris Rosen Giroux in fact
the very senior editor it was mr. Giroux
because the company was at that time
called Ferris Johnson company he was not
yet his name and yet not yet
supportively
of the name of the firm and he said
we're very interested in your book and
he took me to lunch and he offered me an
advance of $500 and I stayed with him
ever since I'm in other words the fairy
tale is and it is a kind of fairy tale
they were the first publisher to whom I
submitted my first book they took it and
I have remained intensely and happily
loyal to this firm headed by Rogers Das
who lives become a great friend of mine
all these all these years and you have
any sense of how many books together
you're sold no but I I have this amazing
good fortune that all my books are in
print with the exception of the two film
scripts all might they they have all
gone into many many paperback editions
I'd like you know I don't may sound
silly but I don't really like to think
about it too much because I know I guess
I don't want to become self-conscious
about well what if what I'm doing is
going to reach a large audience or
or be successful you know that there is
just as when you get older I suppose you
you lose energy or you lose something I
mean because there's just the wear and
tear of age I keep thinking I don't feel
it yet but maybe you know it's there
anyway so I think when you write well
let's put it this way most writers let
me say something very very you know
reckless most writers do their best work
rather early on as certainly in the
first half of their writing lines
assuming that they have relatively long
writing line and the second half of the
work of the second half is not as good
there's some very conspicuous exceptions
Dostoevsky being one where his great he
just got greater and greater and greater
and as great a signal novelist in last
night others Karamazov but by and large
writers unlike painters and unlike
composers where the opposite rule
applies writers fiction writers
generally do their best work in the
first half of their writing much I think
I'm doing that definitely do the better
work now and the second part half I
don't know what it we call that i-i-i-i
seem to have been precocious as a child
but I actually think I'm quite slow and
that I'm really just getting going and I
really feel it's very important not to
be too self-conscious I mean I mean like
you know this isn't being on a program
being on this program above all because
I've never had a three-hour conversation
and anytime I've been on radio in case
sometimes I've been on TV of course you
get very self-conscious and I find
myself I have to be totally honest with
you some of the things that I say or
think now I say or think because I've
said them in response to questions I
never would have said them otherwise
because I'm not very I don't think about
myself very much that may sound odd but
I don't think about myself I mean I
think about what I do or I think about
what I care about but I don't actually
think about well where am I now and I
know a lot of writers do if I I've had
writer friends who have said to me I put
that passage in the book because I knew
that would be the thing that everybody
would pay attention to or like I
wouldn't know how to do that if I wanted
to but I guess I don't want to I think I
want to be a little bit blind about what
I'm doing and not not to think too much
about well what does it mean you know
sometimes people say to me who you
writing for and then I I say sort of a
set phrase I'm writing for the people
who would like the kind of thing that I
do which means I don't want to think
about who I'm writing for the one thing
that I've learned to think about as I as
I get older and that's only because not
because of the particular age I am but
just that I am older is that of course I
want to have younger readers and that's
part of a larger question as to who is
who is reading you know I know I have
readers my own age or somewhat younger
in fact all the time people are coming
up to me practically in wheelchairs with
gray hair gray hair white hair and
glasses and looking to be a hundred
years old and telling you they read read
me when they were children so I say okay
I have those people I have people of a
certain generation maybe I people who
are say from 50 up but do I have readers
who are 25 can I write something that
would matter to those people there's no
way that I can make it happen and
there's no way that's thinking about it
would help me make it happen and there's
no way I can change even if I wanted to
change but I just hope that all this
reality that I try to keep in contact
with will will seep into the work so
that it will matter
insofar as younger people are reading
that it will matter to people who are
much younger because well that's what
everybody wants by way of getting a
little Sontag biography in here we've
got a lot of calls from California this
afternoon and we heard earlier about
Susan Sontag childhood in Arizona there
moved on to California and in fact as a
graduate of North Hollywood High School
all negative you even you laugh people
think it's funny that I graduated from
North Valley I guess because I was born
in New York because I literally was born
in New York but left when I was six
months old people think I'm some kind of
quintessential New Yorker but I'm very
much not a New Yorker and New Yorkers
know that I mean anyway when I first
came to New York every one said all you
smile so much and you know and also I
was friendly in a way that it's changed
now but the New Yorkers weren't and I
couldn't stand AG you and you know the
cliche but it's true in an apartment
building you know people didn't live
there for a very long time and they
don't say hello to each other and I
essentially my formative psychological
experience was the Southwest where
everybody is excruciating Lee pain
painfully friendly and I love that I
love that friendliness I love that hi
don't be a stranger you come back real
soon how's your mom all that stuff and
very native to me at North Hollywood
High School that high school was really
like remember rebel without a cause you
know that was that was my high school I
mean it was very much like that like for
school or even in the last picture show
was that kind of American childhood very
much not one of the on the North East
where I chose to live next color is Los
Angeles hello miss Montague I love your
work you should write a book on how to
maintain youth because you look great
I'm very concerned about the role that
the press and the media in the United
States are playing in enabling the Bush
administration for example my sister
called me this morning and said that The
Guardian which I believe is the paper in
London the headline was that the UN
Security Council I don't know if it's a
rumor or what it has been bugged in the
essence water gated by the Bush
administration all of their homes and
offices and telephones have been bugged
in order to blackmail them into voting
for war and even if you haven't you know
don't know about that still what do you
think about the role that the press and
the media in the u.s. are praying well
there is a you know amidst that the
message that the media are liberal and
that's not
true at all there are some liberal if
you want to use that word I'm suspicious
of all these words I want to use it in
quotation marks there are there a
liberal columnist you know Congress I
greatly admire foreign to be blunt about
it like like Maureen Dowd and Bob
Herbert in the New York Times there are
also other other columnist that could
not be called liberal by any you know
usual use of the term like William faff
that I read very attentively and learn a
lot from there are there are columnist
that do not express the mainstream
Republican view but most papers in this
country of course are armed
supporters of the Bush administration
talk radio is overwhelmingly an
extremely anti-liberal anti democratic
party talk radio is very much dominated
by by fanatics of I would say an anti
liberal cast so where do we get our
information from I mean there are there
are weekly magazines there is a New York
Times which I remain devoted to for all
its faults I think which gives us a
great deal of information I I tell you
once again the computer is a godsend I
read that I read for instance I read The
Guardian and the independent the two
British papers online and I and I also
read because I can read French I read
some French and Belgian papers I think
we have to use the computer those of us
who care about the news because it's not
true that we're getting enough
information and again once again
contrary to what is said and contrary to
the tenor of many questions in in this
particular program which have been
largely supportive of the views that I
hold it's very much not true that the
media are liberal and this is a
right-wing myth that has been foisted on
people and and as apparently for
plausible by many people it's not true
at all just look at television look at
look
the news event on television look at the
editorials and and little cat in
newspapers and Luckett talk radio all in
the opposite direction so it's hard to
get information but you can get
information and informed citizenry as
everybody knows is the basis for
democracy Philadelphia oh hello I I feel
a little bit embarrassed about asking
you my question because it's a small
question your program this program is
concerned with war and genocide in
politics but it's concern all around but
but like you I'm I'm close to your age
and I loved hearing you say that you
have a sense of promise that there are
things to come for you things to do and
so on and I've actually said more than
but I said the better things are yeah
and my work I feel are still to come
not yeah there's always more to come and
told to let it carry out yes yeah
exactly yeah that is a good and I'm
concerned with that very much so because
all of my life I've worked for half of
what the men I worked along with have
made in here pushing 70 I'm still in the
same boat and I work for a lot of men
who tell me that it's not politically
expedient to pay me there's no reason
why they feel compelled to pay me the
way they pay well that's as the men who
tarnishing that anyone would say that I
mean isn't that illegal look what kind
of work do you do oh it's very
surprising I work for a Justice
Commission just kind of ironic and I do
a lot of research and a lot of writing
and so on well it's an equal pay for
equal work is is just the bedrock of any
movement on behalf of women and nobody
should take less or acknowledge that
there's any that it's right to pay women
less for the same work I you know people
sometimes ask me almost timidly would
you call yourself a feminist as if
they're asking me a kind of either of a
kind of delicate question or maybe
they're I'm going to be insulted or
something like that and my reaction is
how can I not be a feminist I mean at
least as I understand feminism I mean
and I have no problem with this word at
all not that I could take it's probably
the only is T word that I actually like
just because I find so many people are
afraid of it I certainly don't call
myself a leftist I don't even call
myself a liberal I don't know what I
call myself I don't want to define
myself politically but I would say I'm a
feminist and what I mean by feminist is
I am devoted to and and passionately
interested in an eager to participate in
any way that I can in the effort to
correct the in justices that are done to
women I don't I don't have any problem
with that if that's what I mean by
feminists then I don't see how you
cannot be a feminist I mean obviously I
don't mean a lot of wacky things that
people have associated that with that
term but I mean the good things that
people in asoto stays with and that
starts with the right of women to be
protected against physical violence and
the right to be paid properly for the
same kind of work and the right to have
access to on equal terms depending on
merit this the same kinds of occupations
so women should be cops and women should
be able to be airline pilots and women
should be able to be orchestra conductor
if they're qualified if they are as good
as an ins competent in their jobs as any
male aspirant to that position that's
where I start from and I I get very
upset when when women including
wonderful women independent women women
who care about all these things don't
don't want to stand up for them because
they again have been talked into the
idea that if they stand up for them
they're somehow being improperly
aggressive toward men this is this is
just a question of justice and this is
obviously something that we should all
care about if you could have chosen your
gender would it have been female
a male when I was a child I certainly
wanted wished I had been a boy
absolutely and I think most women who
are ambitious at least certainly in my
generation or somewhat younger I don't
know about you certainly thought God
life would be easier if you're a boy
just because people wouldn't always be
telling you things you couldn't do you
can't climb that tree you can't get your
dress dirty don't listen up I'll tell
you a very indiscreet story which is
telling you means telling the world I
guess a long time ago in our
conversation probably an hour ago you
asked me about my childhood and why I
bear the name Sontag which is not the
name I was going with Melissa name my
mother's second husband so my mother
remarried when I was 12 we left Tucson
we moved to suburban Los Angeles well I
guess you'd call it suburban Los Angeles
Sherman Oaks and I went to North
Hollywood High School and I can remember
lying it wasn't a very small my my
mother her husband my sister Judith and
myself at a small little house very very
modest and I and I was lying on my
stomach in the living room and I can I
can just see that sort of horrible
little gray pile rug and I was reading
and then this large pair of pants and
shoes was walked by me and of course it
was mr. Sontag we were supposed to call
dad and he looked down and he said sue
and I also I'm telling a indecent thing
I've never said in public which was that
I was called sue until I went away to
college
he said sue if you read so much you'll
never get married and I looked up and I
burst out laughing I thought was the
funniest thing I ever heard in my life
I couldn't imagine I mean some had been
out of the room when they blended the
things that are told the girls that make
them hold back and pretend to be dumb
were said I didn't hear it
I just thought that was hilarious I
thought he was some kind of [ __ ] why in
the world if I became smart would I not
get married I mean I saw there were some
smart
men out there and that that being a
smart woman would be was just a nice
thing to be what was what was wrong with
it
you know but I realized that I was very
lucky I mean I was lucky in the same way
that when I found out I had cancer the
first time I didn't feel ashamed I
didn't feel was something I had to hide
I didn't know that it was a scandal to
have cancer as it was then I'm talking
about a long time ago the first time was
the late 1970s but actually the the
envelopes that came from my hospital
with the bills my hospital was
sloan-kettering and in New York City
which is a Cancer Center it just had the
address it didn't have sloan-kettering
Memorial Cancer Hospital and I asked my
principal oncologist is the reason the
envelopes don't have the name of the
hospital what I think and he said you
bet there are we have patients whose
families don't know they have cancer I
mean living parts of their family whose
neighbors don't know people in the
workplace don't know it's not for us to
reveal that this person is a patient in
our Hospital so you know I mean cancer
was a scandal and make smart if you're a
girl is a scandal because you're going
to scare boys away or you're going to be
seen as aggressive or unfeminine all
these things these are tremendous
obstacles that deform people and and
it's very important to shuttle against
them I think duck sorry Massachusetts
what's your question ah just in time um
I feel like a little question that has
to do with when President Bush was
running for president when they had the
first presidential debate Republican and
he on the moderator asked the question
was you know who was your favorite
leader or on someone who you admired and
his answer was Jesus Christ and if
thought of you know kind of stunned the
moderator and now there's lots of tell
if you remember this i donnelly
remembered but i remember what and what
it was it was philosopher who's your
favorite philosopher right okay not
leader a little bit of a difference yeah
yeah and um he also you know was a
born-again Christian and one of them up
one of my concern
because of the this a lot of the people
involved in his around him is that there
is a religious overtone to this
administration and it's been it's quite
evident and you know I'm I'm a person
who struggles with Christianity I grew
up a very fundamentalist church and the
whole lot the whole concept that the
only way to the father is through the
son if you truly believe that and you're
involved in you know wars with a law
with Iraq in in Muslim nations that I
just like to have you comment and how
you separate this in other words if you
really are a believer in Jesus you know
how can you possibly think about bombing
a country a city like Baghdad which you
know is innocent women and children who
really are at the mercy of this vicious
leader and I just you know I'm
struggling with this and was it was kind
of curious about how you felt about this
well I think it's a very very
interesting very interested question
what you say I am myself a hundred
percent two hundred percent I want to
say secular and the older I get the more
secular I become because I see the
terrible things that are that are that
are done in the name of religion but I I
have struggled again kind of confession
with a lifelong of sympathy moral
sympathy temperamental sympathy and
attraction to Christianity and to the
ethical principles of Christianity and I
you know I think it's very hard to be a
moralist which I certainly am and and
not feel sometimes almost exhausted by
the struggle to have a completely
secular basis for your moral principles
when you almost wish that you could rely
on on one of the great religious
traditions to to formulate the
principles of justice and of
non-violence and of generosity
and of respect it's very important
which-which that the the best parts of
the great religious traditions have
stood for I I think you know when people
talk about the difference between
America and Europe and then these
horrible contemptuous remarks which some
people in the present administration
like mr. Rumsfeld have made old Europe
and old tired Europe you know so tired
and irrelevant they actually don't
believe in war anymore
and and the Robert Kagan book which was
mentioned earlier you know which tries
to set up some kind of enormous cultural
difference between America and Europe
you know I think it to limited extent
there's some truth in that three things
that strike me is very different between
America and Europe we ought to think
about first is the enormous amount of
violence that we tolerate within our own
borders which no European country would
tolerate the fact the right to bear arms
and the right to use them in all sorts
of situations no European country would
would tolerate the crime rate and the
use of firearms but that we permit
second thing is the death penalty most
people in Europe don't understand how
you can use the best death penalty I
mean that doesn't mean they don't care
about punishing criminals they don't
believe in the right of the state to
kill most people in this country
apparently although of course the death
penalty was briefly illegal outlawed by
the Supreme Court I think that that the
death penalty is almost synonymous with
the willingness to punish and they can't
understand the Europe the fact that they
don't believe that in many cases don't
know that in all European countries the
death penalty doesn't exist anymore and
they have much lower crime rates and
don't tell me it because they don't have
poor people they don't have immigrants
they don't have restless adolescent or
males or males in their early 20s who
commit crimes have exactly the same
thing they have murder rates of fraction
of ours and they have no death penalty
in fact not having the death penalty is
a prerequisite for becoming joining the
European Union it's one of turkeys
problems because they still do have the
death penalty
and third and very importantly most
Europeans don't go to church and most
Europeans don't count themselves as
religious yes they may have the children
baptized and they may get married in a
church and may get buried in the church
those three things but they do not
they're not believers and they don't use
a religious language in public life and
they don't think that it's an important
part of their civic identity to turn up
at some religious institution once a
week we had Friday Saturday or Sunday
most people in this country do the
religious language is alive in this
country in a way that it's not in Europe
that is a cultural difference that's a
really important cultural difference and
I I think the shameless way in what
could come back to the caller's question
the shameless way in which this
administration invokes religious
language would shock would dismay would
horrify our greatest presidents
Washington Jefferson Lincoln Roosevelt
all of whom were entirely secular in
their conduct of the office and secular
in their private lives Susan Sontag
latest book assist arriving in
bookstores around the country it's
called regarding the pain of others we
have a half an hour left in a
conversation with her next is Phoenix
yes on tech I am very disappointed that
an educated intellectual left yourself
repeated the old canard about Germany
starting three wars in Europe I hope
you're thinking and writing is not as
defective as your knowledge of history
in 1870 it was France declared war on
the Prussian Confederation Germany did
not exist yet but as France we declared
war in 1914 it was France and Russia
were mobilised before Germany and the
kaiser wilhelm ii bent over backwards to
prevent that war from from expanding and
even in 1939 you know england if not for
england in French you know backing up
Poland Poland they have made they have
made arrangements for Germany for grants
for territory and and work had been
avoided Easter 1939 Hitler was bent down
more you know I agree there no but it
might not have come in 1939
that have spread around the whole world
might have been contained just to
Eastern Europe you know and but I agree
with what you what you said today and I
totally agree with you on the situation
in Iraq and you must be heard you're
like I say I was disappointed it
repeated a canard like that because
you're obviously an educated person and
just Germany starting to World War Z
thanks we got the point appreciate it
wow I never heard that the Germans
didn't start World War two I guess a lot
of different views out there but anyway
I guess we should go on okay we will and
it's next Connersville Indiana you're on
the air yes listen to y'all that plus
it's alright okay I respect your
writings I also respect your views that
I watched here on the TV as citizens we
are being I believe we are being
disenfranchised by our media we've lost
dogs and if we speak out against what
our government this administration is
doing in our name we're being called
everything but Americans were being
demonized and I don't know what we can
do can you help I verb right to their CC
and right into Congress and I've done
this but it doesn't seem to help thank
you
well I think that it's very listen you
can always get people a lot of people to
before war if you say one there's a
threat and you keep repeating that over
and over again there's a threat there's
a threat there's a threat and two if you
oppose the war you're not patriotic now
I think there are other ways to deal
with the threat and the horror that is
the present regime in Iraq
and I feel passionately that those of us
who opposed this war who are critical of
the Bush administration
are patriots I consider myself an
American patriot
and one of the most patriotic things
that I do is to engage in debate and to
express along with many other people and
this is not a little minority position
my dismay and disapproval of the
recklessness and folly of this plan to
invade and occupy let's remember we're
not just talking about invasion and
killing many civilians which of course I
am horrified by we are talking about
occupying a country we're talking about
occupying a country for a very long time
and supposedly bringing about democracy
I do not believe that we're going to
bring about democracy in Iraq if we
occupied I think we're unleashing a
series of consequences which we have no
idea if we pursue this action which
could be very damaging to the region
very damaging to us very damaging to the
world above all damaging for Iraq I
don't know but we want to get this
government to to be overthrown but we
don't want to do it I think in this way
but but you know all we can do is talk
all we can do is make sure that no one
convinces us or puts us on the defensive
that we are not the Patriots we are
Patriots just as much and I think better
Patriots more intelligent Patriots and
the people pushing for this folly
we have two questions by email about
film and in the interesting at home I'm
going to join them together Christopher
Harrison Orlando Florida writes over the
years you have written some of the most
deeply penetrating and probing film
criticism I've read my question for you
is what what recent films and or
contemporary filmmakers do you consider
the most compelling and there instead
expense abilities and why and somewhat
related David say in Davis California
says I understand you are currently
presenting a series of Japanese films at
the Japan Society
for those of us too far away to attend
what is your interest in Japanese film
oh these are dream questions well yes
film is my lifelong love I'm always
thinking out at five o'clock to go to
the movies I figure if I work all day I
know the movies at five o'clock and I
love to see I love the big screen
ah film film is a just a source of
unending pleasure and an intense
interest to me because because of I
don't know I kind of almost like a moral
education that I feel I always much to
film as I do to literature a portrayal
of people understanding of the world
narrative pleasure visual pleasure
pleasure of the senses
they're wonderful filmmakers now let me
let me think of some filmmakers I
particularly like you can to choose
independence or well I tend to choose
what I what I you know what I like I
mean I guess in some cases I supposedly
call independence I mean I and I don't
have any particular genre life like like
one of the American films that I that I
love the most in recent years was a kind
of animated film called waking life by a
director named Richard Lee Linklater uh
I think my favorite directors right now
are not Americans I love a Russian
director named Alexander Sokolov who has
the film is playing now called Russian
arc which is just gonna let me put this
way I like unique films I like films
that are over the top I like films that
are better I guess some people would say
very weird this sakarov film for
instance it's 90 minutes long it's all
one shot and has 3,000 people in it it's
a one-of-a-kind film it's not at all
typical these other films I mean they're
even on the surface of it I like better
but he's a Russian directory's
absolutely amazing he's not very well
known this first film that's had some
kind of breakthrough in the theatrical
distribution but the audience for
foreign films in this country is
relatively small but then they exist in
DVDs and they get and Shonen you know
and
TV cable and so on I love a Hungarian
director named Bella Tarr I love a
director from Hong Kong named Wong
kar-wai I I love some Iranian film some
of those wonderful films the last 10
years have come from Iran there is a
great director named Abbas Kiarostami
whose films I adore there's a very young
woman whose father is a well-known
director
her name is some some year I believe
Samira mock ma ba there is a terrific
Taiwanese director named Edward yang who
did a film called Yi a few years ago I
and then I see a lot of films over and
over again the way I read poetry again
or look at paintings I have a series of
Japan Film Society excuse me at the
Japan Society which has a wonderful film
program of Japanese films a lot of them
are from the 50s and 60s and I love
their their humanity and their portraits
of sadness and complicated relationships
I guess I guess what I miss in a lot of
a lot of Hollywood films is just that
kind of going inside people you know
that how the Hollywood films are so
often targeted for a very young audience
that that's looking for hyper sensations
and sure I like some of those things - I
also like Japanese anime you know if
that's pure sensation but I like films
for grown-ups and I like films that you
can Ricci in a way what I feel about
films is what I feel about literature
that I don't want to see a movie that I
wouldn't want to see again so I do see a
lot of if I go out to the movies a lot I
live in a town New York City where you
can see old movies you know you have
repertory cinemas but I think that's
true here in Washington and it's true in
a lot of large cities that there one or
two theaters I don't know I mean in
Chicago for instance there's a little
cinema Petra that's run by facets video
that shows all films in Berkeley and Sam
Cisco and Los Angeles and you know you
see films everywhere if you want to I
have a caller from Prescott Arizona but
very quickly are you one of those kinds
of persons who will or will not go to
the movies alone that's always a
dividing line oh how interesting you ask
that no I definitely will go along first
of all I can't always get somebody to
come and play because I'm always calling
people up and saying listen I'm going to
there's a Fassbender retrospective right
now at Film Forum I'm I'm going down at
five o'clock to you know oh I'm sorry I
have to wash my hair or I have a temp to
do something or I have to I haven't
finished my work and I think I'll come
on
do it later you know I'm you know what
Oscar Wilde said I can resist everything
except temptation so I'm very easy to
tempt away from my work and most leave
are much more conscientious than I am
but here's the interesting thing Susan
if I see a movie with somebody I have
many more ideas about it if not but
that's the point of going to movies it's
certainly not the point is pleasure but
if I if I see a movie with someone then
I talk about it with the person when I
leave and then I actually have ideas in
talking because I hardly ever have any
ideas except if I'm talking or writing
otherwise it's just dreaming it's not
ideas at all but if I see a movie alone
I just come out completely you know
dazed and I'm still in the movie but
ever have any ideas about it so it's a
different experience it's not
necessarily a bad experience I don't
mind doing it I'll feel lonely but I
don't have that after experience you
know which is being able to talk about
it Prescott Arizona glance hello I
appreciate your view that I would call
maybe selective intervention ism that
that you wanted that you might
appreciate a foreign policy where we
stressed an awareness of our limitations
at solving people's problems and yet
we're willing say in in the case of very
able to to target certain obvious
Arsenal's and gun emplacements that were
just so blatantly cruel that is that we
didn't need a grand strategy to justify
and possibly even some car
intervention to make Belgrad a little
uncomfortable with their political
leadership and yet in other words had we
had we been willing to act sooner but a
lot less comprehensively at not claiming
we had responsibility for solving their
problems but just out of moral outrage
at certain points to be constructively
interventionist I think I'd like to hear
how you might apply that to our current
situation well here's the thing this is
very very important I asked myself this
question all the time how could I have
been for the intervention in Bosnia and
Kosovo not be for the one in Iraq you
know I've discussed this question by
email with a friend of mine Ariel
Dorfman the the Chilean writer and he
he's excited I speak out of one
experience which is I lived and and put
my life on the line you know
siding with Bosnia and choosing to live
in the city during the siege he said he
was a refugee from the Pinochet era in
Chile and you know he and we both agree
that there are certain times when you
want to intervene and there other times
when you're even if you you know leaving
aside any other motives which we might
think that are empowering the Bush
administration because I I'm willing to
give them a lot of credit to the except
I don't think it's just oil I think
there are some sincere ideologues there
in the administration who really believe
in democracy building as a possibility
in the Middle East I'm not saying
they're all just a bunch of cynical you
know oil executives you know wanting to
to make the world safer for you know the
oil industry or anything like that but
when would you want to do it and when
wouldn't you want to do it now in the
case of Bosnian Kosovo it was supposed
to be a relatively minimal application
enforce certainly in Bosnia it was it
was far too late I don't think a single
person died and then in the so called
NATO bombing but it finally came in late
1995 in Kosovo and then Belgrade of
course there were civilian casualties
and that had to do with a military
policy which I did not
agree which which was bombing from so
high they couldn't often tell the
difference where they where they were
dropping their palms but in anyway
the purpose was a very limited one it
was not to occupy Serbia it was not it
was not to remake the Balkans it was to
stop a war to stop a dictator and it had
a limited good effect we are talking
about I believe in the case of this
projected war which the Americans want
to do you know now the latest thing is
Bush's said unless Saddam leaves a total
disarmament wouldn't even be enough
Saddam Hussein has to leave for us to be
to call off the war but I don't think
anything will call it up what they're
talking about is reconfiguring a whole
area and they're talking about a
military occupation which will involve a
huge commitment of hundred possibly
hundreds of thousands of American
soldiers far I think beyond our means to
do at least do in the positive way that
it's being claimed that it will be that
it will be accomplished so the question
is what is the goal are you just
stopping something are you taking over
I think there's it's different from stop
and to take over if we could stop Saddam
Hussein but I don't think it's necessary
to invade to do that that I think that
would be absolutely positive objective
but we do have to question the whole
principle as to whether it is the
American job and only a great Empire
would so conceived its job to intervene
wherever it decides something bad is
going on bad things are going on
everywhere and we're not simply
intervening in order to stop bad things
inevitably we will have basis we will at
the very least we have military
implantation there and real control and
the examples from World War two Japan
and Germany those limited occupations I
think are not proper models for what is
coming up in the Middle East we're going
to be there forever New York City that's
right you know thank you we talked about
civilization and the future but what
about civilization in the past you look
at Iraq and it's one of the oldest will
another country but the people are
living
and that's one of the oldest
civilizations using the Mesopotamians
and I'm not sure if or was also in that
area yes yeah sure and why and also you
talked about the northwest and how
people say hello and they stop
acknowledge your family and you know
that if you go to Iraq even as an
American somebody would invite you into
their home and be extremely hospitable
why is it that we do not why's that so
many of us do not see others as complex
human beings well you know I think it's
even agree entirely with what you said
but I think it's even worse I actually
know a very close friend of mine had a
had a conversation last week with a an
educated woman I mean you know all the
right qualifications to have a more
complicated view who said to her I don't
see why we don't just drop a lot of
nuclear weapons I'm out of bombs on
Baghdad and get it all over with and my
friend said but but those are people
there how could you consider that and
she said I don't care about anything
except American lives now I actually
think that's a view that has quite a lot
of credibility in this country anything
for American lives I mean it's what gets
what gets people to refer back to a
rather intemperate earlier questioner
why it would never occur to him to
question the atomic bombing of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki the very thought that this
might have saved American lives is
enough for him to find it completely
justified to have killed all those
civilians certainly they were not
military targets I feel that Americans
for Americans there are American lives
and that's why we have had up to now I
wonder if we're going to be able to keep
it up in Iraq a policy of minimal
casualties
the idea is to conduct a military
operation
so basically no American soldiers die
look look at the way the what
happened in Afghanistan look at what
happened in Bosnia and in Kosovo the
idea is to bomb from on high and to lose
no I mean more Americans in recent
military adventures of the United States
have died in road accidents than of they
are from so-called friendly fire that is
mistakes on the part of American bombing
missions that have actually been killed
by foreign soldiers so we have a
situation which an American life is
worth is priceless and other people's
lives have very little value not just in
a traditional society the poor Iraqis
who have suffered so much
are gone at the hands of Saddam Hussein
are now going to suffer more and this D
does not bother most people in the lives
of foreigners we have a double standard
and our lives are precious the lives of
American soldiers are precious when I
say we I mean there are a lot of things
that Americans do that I think any
country with American power would
probably do the same the British were
beastly when they were the great
Imperial nation it's not a Americans
have a unique capacity for wickedness
but in this respect I think Americans
are rather unique in the value that they
place on American lives in contrast to
all other lives the French and the
British and their great imperial
ventures sacrifice soldiers at an
incredible clip and not no peep out of
the civilian population back home but
the this government has set up an
expectation of very low casualty rates I
don't know if that will be maintained in
this war or not we have seven minutes
left in our three hours of Susan Sontag
we've gotten a number of her titles
under the camera let me just quickly
show you a few others if you're new to
her writing under the son of Saturn
Alice in bed I etcetera and death kit
Berkeley California you're on the air i
I'm so glad I got truth I'm originally
from South America and I read your books
first in Spanish Spanish translation and
that I am able to read in English I'm
I'm glad I can
i speaking of literary genres you have
written essays on novels and books on
photography and and and some other
topics and but my question is how do you
feel when you write an essay how does
the novelist thing you feel and how does
the essays that feel when you write a
novel since you said that you feel more
or do you put more of yourself I think
that's what you said in in the two
novels or you feel more or do you feel
closer to the novel's than to the essay
yeah I do
I definitely feel closer to the novel
form and I guess it's some kind of
masochism that I've written so many
essays I like the I like the the throne
voice I like to throw my voice into
somebody else's voice I like
transformation I like self-contradiction
a novel is a big ship and you can even
put essay elements in a novel and I do I
mean I do in these last two novels the
volcano lover the main character is a
collector and I have a lot of remarks
about what it is to obsession of being a
collector a lot of stuff about America
in the most recent novel in America so
you could put essay elements in a novel
but you can't really put novelistic or
fictional elements in an essay essay is
one voice in which for the time of the
essay you have to believe that what
you're saying is true at least I have to
believe it's true but of course as soon
as I'm finished I always think yes but I
always think there's more to say and
there is more to say and as much as I
try to to kind of do things with the
essay form so I can go faster and
include more contradictions and then you
have to follow a line and you and you
have to have views and of course I've
been you know spending three hours with
my charming interlocutor expressing a
whole lot of views and I do think there
are other things to say and even I even
know some things
that I would want to argue with if we
had another three hours god forbid
so I I think that not what's great about
the novel is it can express this
polyphonic or multiple point of view you
can put one thing you think or feel in
one character in another in another car
because we're complicated with full of
contradictions that's the main thing
essays however complicated they are and
passionate and I hope truthful they
express something smaller so the
essayist in me is quite happy when the
novelist is allowed to work and the
novelist is quite frustrated when the
SAS does it works how many languages
have you been translated into 32 there's
a lot of languages I my translations
because because I work so hard because
I'm a tremendous rewriter I'm the
opposite of some writers who think it
all out men just write it down I my
first draft are I think very mediocre
and but there's something there and then
I just keep rewriting and rewriting and
rewriting and rewriting and get to
something and I'm very by one of my best
qualities that has stood me in very good
stead both as a writer and as a patient
is I'm a very stubborn I'm very
tenacious and I'm very patient and I
will do what is necessary so I work that
hard on the language than I think oh my
god how is it being translated but I can
only check the translations in a couple
of languages Chicago yeah I thanks for
taking my call I had a quick question
it's a subject you touched on earlier
regarding your audience and and who you
write for and I think you mentioned that
you quite simply wrote for yourself I
know I said I know I didn't re items I
wrote for myself I said that I felt
embarrassed or or it felt presumptuous
to imagine uh who I was writing for
listen if I if you really want to know
who I'm writing for I'm writing for the
dead I'm writing for the great dead I'm
writing for people who are much smarter
than me and much better writers than me
and thinking I could what I write have
anything to do or be a possibly on the
same level as what I admire I'm somebody
absolutely driven by admiration
so all I can connect with is from the
past and the standards from the past but
I'm not writing for myself
I mean I'm nobody I'm just the
instrument you know I'm writing to be
read of course not not nothing to do
with me Scott oh I'm sorry yeah you're
writing to be read and equipment in this
modern culture of artists to where
literature might be in some circles
considered to be being washed over by TV
and in some of these other pappa media
institutions do you feel like you're
missing some readers who don't have the
opportunity to participate in the level
of writing how old are you caller iris
how old are you I'm 27 all right there's
your younger we yeah well tell you tell
you I'm I'm a big I'm an evangelist I'm
a preacher III I'm always trying to turn
people on to things and I know that
people of your age a little shy about
reading they're almost like they're once
said to be I'm afraid of being bored I
said try it I don't think you're gonna
be bored I think a lot of people were
very young or missing the pleasures of
reading I'm not afraid of missing it's
done in do with me I'm worried about
them they don't have to read me but I
want them to read I don't know I want
them to read Whitman and I want to read
Emily Dickinson I want them to read
Dostoyevsky and Faubert and Zachary and
Dickens and Proust and maan and Joyce
and I want them to read all those books
that mattered to me so they'll have
experiences they could never get from
all the entertainment media I'm not
against entertainment and I don't know
they're only 24 hours in a day but
derogate they're missing you you you're
not one of them obviously wouldn't even
be asking the question but people are
are missing out on something and they
should all of a sudden at the end that
goes very quickly but thank you very
much for spending three hours with
c-span's audience we appreciate it it
was a wonderful treat ours Thank You
Susan Susan Sontag and her books all
available in your local library or
bookstore thanks for being with us we'll
be back again the first Sunday of next
month with in-depth
you've been watching in-depth with Susan
Sontag if you missed any portion of the
three-hour interview you can see the
program again at 5:00 p.m. Eastern